programming throwdown episode 70 cobalt and mainframes take it away jason hey everyone um so you know we actually we get a lot of emails of people saying, hey, can you advertise, you know, our new, I don't know, energy drink or something. We don't actually get energy drink. I just don't want to call anyone out. And we don't everything we advertise or everything we talk about, I should say, are things we legitimately use. We don't just I think the word is shill. We don't just shill for people um and it's kind of part of proving that um i uh i was on udacity because i was uh interested in uh game theory plus reinforcement learning so uh for people who don't know i did my phd in
Programming Throwdown 第 70 期，Cobalt 和大型机，Jason 你来主持吧。嘿，大家好，嗯，你知道我们其实收到了很多邮件，人们说：“嘿，你们能帮我们宣传一下我们的新能量饮料之类的吗？”其实我们并没有收到能量饮料。我只是不想点名任何人。而且我们宣传或谈论的所有东西，我应该说，都是我们真正使用过的。我们不仅仅是——我想那个词是“托儿”（shill）。我们不仅仅是为别人当托儿，嗯，这其实也是证明的一部分。嗯，我之前在 Udacity 上课，因为我对博弈论加强化学习很感兴趣，所以对于那些不知道的人，我是在攻读博士学位时……
reinforcement learning and i've also been just really fascinated with game theory and now those two things are actually starting to come together so game theory has advanced to the point where economists don't know what to do um and we'll talk about that a little bit and reinforcement learning has gotten to the point where like uh machine learning engineers are kind of stuck and they actually come right together. And they're both kind of on this crash course. So I put that into YouTube just to kind of see, you know, what I would get, you know, what people are thinking about that. And I got a Udacity course. It was actually the last video in the machine learning course was the first result. And basically it was Michael Littman, who's pretty famous in the reinforcement learning community. And he's like, yeah, we don't know how to solve
强化学习，而且我也一直对博弈论非常着迷，现在这两者实际上开始融合了。博弈论已经发展到经济学家们都不知道该怎么办的地步了，嗯，我们会稍微谈谈这个。而强化学习也发展到了机器学习工程师们有点卡壳的地步，它们实际上走到了一起。它们都在经历一场碰撞。所以我把这些输入到 YouTube 上，只是想看看我能得到什么，人们对此有什么看法。我找到了一个 Udacity 的课程。实际上，机器学习课程中的最后一个视频就是第一个搜索结果。基本上是 Michael Littman，他在强化学习领域非常有名。他说：“是的，我们不知道如何解决……”
this. He's like, here's some ideas, but I have no idea. So it didn't really help me that much. Actually, the ideas were some pretty good leads. But it was pretty cool that like Udacity is pretty pretty integrated in YouTube and all that. But basically, just to kind of fill everyone in, so when you think about game theory, you think about sort of these two-player zero-sum games. Like, for example, or maybe not always zero-sum, but for one person to win, the other has to lose. And so, for example, there's this game called Matching Pennies.
“这个。”他说：“这里有一些想法，但我毫无头绪。”所以它对我并没有太大帮助。实际上，这些想法提供了一些不错的线索。但 Udacity 在 YouTube 上整合得相当好，这很酷。但基本上，为了让大家了解情况，当你想到博弈论时，你会想到那种双人零和博弈。例如，或者也许不总是零和，但对于一个人来说，要赢，另一个人就必须输。所以，例如，有一个游戏叫“猜硬币”（Matching Pennies）。
Actually, Matching Pennies isn't zero-sum. Oh, there's like Prisoner's Dilemma is one. Prisoner's Dilemma also isn't zero-sum, but this idea where there's these two people, and they both get put in two separate rooms and some you know invest imagine you and a friend commit some crime together and they put you in two separate rooms and they say okay you know you need to confess and if you confess then we're going to give you less time in jail uh if you don't confess and we find you guilty, you're going to get hammered, right?
其实，“猜硬币”不是零和博弈。哦，还有像“囚徒困境”这样的游戏。囚徒困境也不是零和博弈，但这个想法是，有两个人，他们都被关在两个独立的房间里，想象你和一个朋友一起犯了某种罪，他们把你关在两个独立的房间里，然后说：“好吧，你需要坦白，如果你坦白，我们就给你减刑；如果你不坦白，而我们发现你有罪，你就会受到严惩，对吧？”
So if you confess, like let's say Patrick and I are in this situation. We rob a bank or something. We get busted. We're in two separate cells. And I say, yep, you know, I did it. And Patrick says, yep, Jason did it. Then I'm in big trouble. I'm going to take like the entire, I'm going to be the perpetrator and I'm going to be the instigator. And I'm
所以如果你坦白，比如我和 Patrick 处于这种情况。我们抢劫了一家银行之类的。我们被抓了。我们被关在两个独立的牢房里。我说：“是的，我知道，是我干的。”而 Patrick 说：“是的，是 Jason 干的。”那我就会有大麻烦了。我将承担全部责任，我将成为肇事者，我将成为主谋，而且我……
going to get this huge sentence and Patrick's going to go free. Right. And vice versa. Right. If we both say, yeah, we did it, then we'll get a little bit of a sentence. Like we'll get a reduced sentence for being honest. And if we both say none of us had anything to do with it, then the police have no evidence and we get off, let's say, scot-free. That's the best, right? We might go to there because it's hard for us to trust each other. Like if I say, you know, actually, sorry, the best is for us both to say we did it and then we both get a reduced sentence. If we both say we didn't do it, then we both get a pretty long sentence. So we both want to say we did it. We both want to say we committed the crime together. And then we kind of will both get some punishment, but not that big a punishment because we admitted it.
我会得到很重的判决，而 Patrick 会被释放。对吧。反之亦然。对吧。如果我们都说：“是的，是我们干的”，那么我们都会得到一点判决。就像我们会因为诚实而获得减刑。如果我们都说我们和这件事没关系，那么警察就没有证据，我们就可以，比如说，逍遥法外。那是最好的，对吧？我们可能会那样做，因为我们很难信任对方。比如如果我说，你知道，其实，抱歉，最好是我们俩都说我们干了，然后我们俩都得到减刑。如果我们都说我们没干，那么我们俩都会得到很长的刑期。所以我们都想说我们干了。我们都想说我们一起犯了罪。然后我们都会受到一些惩罚，但不会是太大的惩罚，因为我们承认了。
But the danger is if I say, yeah, I did it, hoping that Patrick's going to do the same. Patrick could just say, you know, I didn't do it. And I get the full sentence so if patrick knows that i'm admitting guilt if he knew that then he would obviously just say i didn't do it and he would get off right um and so game theory that's kind of one example of like one of these complicated situations right like if you don't have any communication with the other person then you have to like just deeply trust them or you just say, you know, I didn't do it and hope that they do the same thing or not do the same thing. But just it puts you in what's called a Nash equilibrium, which just means that if I say I didn't do it, then that's and Patrick says he didn't do it.
但危险在于，如果我说：“是的，我干了”，希望 Patrick 也会这样做。Patrick 可能只会说：“我没干。”那我就会被判全刑。所以如果 Patrick 知道我承认了罪行，如果他知道这一点，他显然只会说他没干，然后他就会被释放，对吧？嗯，所以博弈论，这只是这类复杂情况的一个例子，对吧？比如如果你和对方没有任何沟通，那么你必须深深地信任他们，或者你只是说：“你知道，我没干”，并希望他们做同样的事情，或者不做同样的事情。但这让你处于所谓的“纳什均衡”中，这意味着如果我说我没干，而 Patrick 说他没干。
That's sort of the best we can do with no information anyways it's a little bit kind of you know it's a complicated subject there's a lot of super interesting work on it um but then there's this question of what happens when you have three players um and it turns out when you have three players or a non-zero-sum game like that prisoner's dilemma things get really really really complicated um it's almost as if think of it like this like it's pretend like you didn't know what a for loop was and so you're writing like you know you have to sort 10 numbers and you actually do it by writing all the instructions like you do a bubble sort like writing all the instructions. Like you do a bubble sort, like literally all the instructions, like an unrolled for loop, because you don't know what a for loop is. And then all
在没有信息的情况下，这已经是我们能做的最好的了。总之，这是一个复杂的主题，有很多非常有趣的研究，嗯，但随后就出现了当你有三个玩家时会发生什么的问题。事实证明，当你拥有三个玩家或像囚徒困境那样的非零和博弈时，事情会变得非常非常复杂。这几乎就像是，想象一下，假设你不知道什么是 for 循环，所以你在写代码，比如你要对 10 个数字进行排序，你实际上是通过写出所有的指令来完成的，就像你做冒泡排序一样，写出所有的指令。就像你做冒泡排序一样，字面上所有的指令，就像一个展开的 for 循环，因为你不知道什么是 for 循环。然后突然……
of a sudden they say, okay, now you have to sort 10,000 numbers, right? Without a for loop, like you're kind of in trouble, right? And that's kind of where economists are with, you know, multiplayer game theory is they think about things at this kind of level of detail, but it's hard to sort of abstract that, and it's hard to, like, scale that out, let's say, right? On the other side of the fence, there's reinforcement learning where they can easily handle, like, huge games. Like, you could play chess, or you could play Go,
他们说：“好吧，现在你需要对 10,000 个数字进行排序。”对吧？没有 for 循环，你就有麻烦了，对吧？这就是经济学家在多人博弈论方面所处的境地，他们以这种细节水平思考问题，但很难将其抽象化，也很难将其扩展，对吧？在围栏的另一边，有强化学习，他们可以轻松处理大型游戏。比如，你可以玩国际象棋，或者你可以玩围棋，
or you could play one of these games where there's just like you know millions and millions of different ways the game could be played and it still works but reinforcement learning only works on two player zero sum games like go is an example like there's two people and then at the end of Go, one person wins and the other person loses. There's no in between. You can't like both win or anything like that. And so as soon as you go to like a three player game or something like Prisoner's Dilemma where both people could win if they choose certain strategies,forcement learning doesn't really know what to do there. And so there's sort of this sweet spot where when you have these kind of complicated games, like imagine a three-player game of Go or something like that.
或者你可以玩这些游戏中的任何一个，游戏有数百万种玩法，而且它仍然有效。但强化学习只适用于双人零和博弈，比如围棋就是一个例子，有两个人，在围棋结束时，一个人赢，另一个人输。没有中间地带。你不能像两者都赢之类的。所以一旦你进入像三人游戏或囚徒困境这样的游戏，如果他们选择特定的策略，双方都可以赢，强化学习真的不知道该怎么办。所以有一个最佳点，当你拥有这些复杂的博弈时，比如想象一个三人围棋游戏之类的。
Nobody really knows how to solve that. The game theory people can't scale up, and the reinforcement learning people don't know how to handle three players. And so it's just this hole. And this is something kind of like super fascinating and i've been kind of really diving deep on it um and uh you know it's just i think it's kind of amazing that so many kind of research papers are are out in the open now you don't have to like i don't know patrick do you remember this when you had to like subscribe to science direct or you had to use a login from the university library to read research
没有人真正知道如何解决这个问题。博弈论的人无法扩展，而强化学习的人不知道如何处理三个玩家。所以这只是一个空白。这是我非常着迷的事情，我一直在深入研究它，嗯，而且你知道，我认为令人惊奇的是，现在有这么多研究论文公开了，你不需要，我不知道，Patrick，你还记得吗，当你不得不订阅 Science Direct 或者你必须使用大学图书馆的登录名来阅读研究……
papers i didn't do it often but yes i do remember when it was much harder to get stuff yeah i was like yeah buy this research paper for 50 you know that was curated with government money it's like they finally kind of stopped a lot of that um and so it's it's it's pretty awesome that that with between like udacity youtube you know free and open research papers that uh you know you can dive deep on almost any topic and that's sort of what i'm binging on right now um did you take any like game theory courses or any like was it part of like microeconomics or anything like that i'm sure it was talked about in some economics course, but I never, I was always sort of self-learning and reading about it.
论文的时候？我没怎么做过，但是的，我记得当时获取资料要困难得多。是的，我当时想：“花 50 美元买这篇研究论文”，你知道，那是用政府资金策划的。好像他们终于停止了大部分这种做法。所以，在 Udacity、YouTube、免费和开放的研究论文之间，你可以深入研究几乎任何主题，这真是太棒了，这正是我现在正在沉迷的事情。你有没有参加过任何博弈论课程，或者它是微观经济学的一部分之类的？我相信在某些经济学课程中提到过，但我从来没有，我一直是在自学和阅读相关内容。
It isn't talked about that much. Yeah, same here. I mean, we had a, we had a, well, I had a game theory course in grad school, but other than that, I mean, I kind of elected to take that. But yeah, in general, it's a topic that is actually super interesting. I mean, anytime you have any type of negotiation or there's an auction, like you're on eBay buying something, there's game theory at play there. One kind of really interesting game theory problem is called the Keynesian Beauty Contest.
它并没有被谈论太多。是的，我也是。我的意思是，我们在研究生院有一门博弈论课程，但除此之外，我的意思是，我选择去上那门课。但总的来说，这是一个非常有趣的话题。我的意思是，任何时候你有任何类型的谈判或拍卖，比如你在 eBay 上买东西，博弈论就在其中发挥作用。一个非常有趣的博弈论问题被称为“凯恩斯选美竞赛”。
Have you heard of this? I think you were the one who told me about this. I might have now is this the one where everyone votes on like who is the prettiest person and you get a chance of winning if you voted for the person who ended up being the prettiest person uh close so the way it works is uh i think you have the right idea but it's it's not the prettiest it's actually the person in the middle. So everyone picks a number between one and let's say a hundred. And if you get the median, you get a thousand dollars.
你听说过这个吗？我想是你告诉我的。我可能听过，这是每个人投票选出谁是最漂亮的人，如果你投票给最终被选为最漂亮的人，你就有机会获胜吗？接近了，它的工作方式是，嗯，我想你的想法是对的，但不是最漂亮的，实际上是中间的那个人。所以每个人都在 1 到 100 之间选一个数字。如果你得到了中位数，你就得到一千美元。
So there's going to be some people who will call them like level zero people. These are people who are just going to pick a random number. Like they're not going to really know what to do. Right. And so let's assume that everyone's a level zero person. Everyone's just picking random numbers from one to a hundred and you want to pick the median. Well, you're going to pick, you know, 50, right? Because there's going to be a whole range of numbers and you're going to pick the one in the middle. But there's going to be some people who are going to think the same way that you just did. So there's going to be a group of people who are all going to pick 50. And what that's going to be some people who are going to think the same way that you just did. So there's going to be a group of people who are all going to pick 50.
所以会有一些人，我们称他们为“零级”人。这些人只是随便选一个数字。他们真的不知道该做什么。对吧。所以假设每个人都是零级人。每个人都只是从 1 到 100 中随机选择数字，而你想选出中位数。好吧，你会选 50，对吧？因为会有各种各样的数字，你会选中间的那个。但会有一些人会像你刚才那样思考。所以会有一群人都会选 50。而那会是……会有一些人会像你刚才那样思考。所以会有一群人都会选 50。
And what that's going to do is that's going to, you know, make the middle go lower. Right. So if there's actually sorry, it can't be 50. Let's say it's the bottom one third or something. So a bunch of people are going to pick 33. And that's going to make the middle kind of go lower, which is going to make the median go lower, which means if everyone, for example, if half the people pick 33 and half the people pick just any number, then you want to pick something less. I think it's like 25 or something. You can calculate what it is. But then you can keep kind of doing this.
而这会使中间值变低。对吧。所以如果，其实抱歉，不可能是 50。假设是底部三分之一之类的。所以一群人会选 33。这会使中间值变低，这意味着如果每个人，例如，如果一半人选 33，一半人随便选一个数字，那么你想选一个更小的数字。我想是 25 左右。你可以计算出它是多少。但然后你可以继续这样做。
You can keep saying, doing this you can keep saying oh there's going to be some people who are going to think two steps ahead and so i should think three steps ahead or i should try and figure out how many people are going to think two steps ahead and yeah this this whole stuff is super fascinating and it turns out whenever you're dealing with like auctions or these type of like financial negotiations, the stock market, stuff like that, all of it has sort of the game theory kind of built in. Like there's agents who are, you know, calculating all of this. There's all the quantitative trading is based on this. And it's definitely worth checking out. I'm going to post a link to the YouTube video,
你可以继续说，你可以继续说：“哦，会有一些人会提前两步思考，所以我应该提前三步思考，或者我应该试着弄清楚有多少人会提前两步思考。”是的，这些东西非常迷人，事实证明，每当你处理拍卖或这类金融谈判、股市等事情时，所有这些都内置了博弈论。就像有代理人在计算所有这些。所有的量化交易都是基于此的。这绝对值得一看。我会发布一个 YouTube 视频的链接，
the audacity, that part of the, not the end of the course where I went, but, but the part that starts talking about game theory. And it's actually Michael Littman, who is a super genius and another gentleman who I don't remember his name, but he's a, he's actually a pure economist. And the two of them together talk about game theory and reinforcement learning. And then together they just hypothesize what to do you know now that they've crashed into each other um so yeah check it out i think for game theory one of the things for me is and this doesn't exactly fall into the economic standpoint but understanding
那个 Udacity 的视频，不是课程结尾我去看的那部分，而是开始谈论博弈论的那部分。实际上是 Michael Littman，他是一个超级天才，还有另一位我不记得名字的绅士，但他是一位纯粹的经济学家。他们两人一起谈论博弈论和强化学习。然后他们一起假设在它们碰撞之后该怎么做。所以，是的，去看看吧。我认为对于博弈论，对我来说，这并不完全属于经济学观点，但理解……
that each actor in some situation that you might encounter in work or life or whatever has a different perspective they're viewing and they're trying to make their own decisions based on what you're doing just like you are trying to make a decision based on what they're doing yeah actually you you hit the nail on the head so like the uh the current like best idea for solving this problem where let's say you have like a good example of this is there's this game called dota defense of the ancients and it's a it's a five versus five game on the computer and there's there's people who are trying to uh you know have an ai play that game but you can imagine you know ai you know robots playing soccer or or uh uh AI people really playing any type of team game like Counter-Strike or Team
在工作或生活中遇到的任何情况下的每个参与者都有不同的视角，他们正在观察，并试图根据你的行为做出自己的决定，就像你试图根据他们的行为做出决定一样。是的，你确实说到了点子上。所以，比如，目前解决这个问题的最佳想法是，假设你有一个很好的例子，这个游戏叫 Dota（远古遗迹守卫），这是一个电脑上的 5 对 5 游戏，有人试图让 AI 玩那个游戏，但你可以想象，机器人踢足球，或者 AI 玩任何类型的团队游戏，比如反恐精英或团队……
Portress or something. None of these AIs are really any good because they can't really cooperate. And it turns out the way to sort of get the cooperation and the multiplayer is there's a technique now called neural fictitious uh self-play which sounds kind of weird but basically uh um it's as you said you know you are trying to do what's best for you but you also keep a mental model of all your opponents and you play the best response to their to what you expect them to do so you know for example, if you know there's this amazing chess move, but you also know that your opponent has never played that move before, given that circumstance, then you're not going to plan for that.
要塞之类的。这些 AI 都没有什么用，因为它们无法真正合作。事实证明，实现合作和多人游戏的方法是，现在有一种技术叫“神经虚拟自我博弈”（neural fictitious self-play），听起来有点奇怪，但基本上，正如你所说，你试图做对自己最有利的事情，但你也保留了所有对手的心理模型，并对你期望他们做的事情做出最佳反应。所以，你知道，例如，如果你知道有一个惊人的国际象棋走法，但你也知道你的对手以前从未走过那一步，在这种情况下，你就不会为此做计划。
You're going to assume that he's going to miss it again, and you're going to play the best response to what you think he's going to do. And so it kind of gets into this keynesian beauty contest where like if you do that but you know he's going to do this and then it kind of it ends up being this sort of recursive thing um but yeah that's kind of where the state of the art is right now is in like this opponent modeling and all that makes sense i yeah i wish i had a more academic i should probably become more academically rigorous about my understanding of game theory but maybe it would help or maybe it wouldn't i'm not sure like as far as like a practical day-to-day life like you talked
你会假设他会再次错过它，并且你会对你认为他会做的事情做出最佳反应。所以它有点进入了这种凯恩斯选美竞赛，就像如果你这样做，但你知道他会这样做，然后它最终变成了一种递归的东西。但是的，这就是目前最先进的状态，在对手建模方面，所有这些都有意义。是的，我希望我有更学术的……我可能应该在对博弈论的理解上变得更严谨，但也许这会有帮助，也许不会，我不确定。就像在实际的日常生活中，你之前……
previously you recommended a book on sort of negotiation and it's clear how that applies day-to-day do you think studying more game theory theory oh man studying more game theory in an academic sense past you know sort of a peripheral superficial understanding do you think that has benefits to like how actually stuff happens out in society i think um i think I think the high-level concepts, yes. So in other words, this idea that there's going to be some group of people who are going to think one step ahead, some are going to think two, three, four steps ahead. And that the interesting part is trying to figure out what fraction of the population is going to think so many steps ahead. So then you could build sort of like the meta system. Like I feel like that can translate into real life.
你推荐了一本关于谈判的书，很明显它在日常生活中是如何应用的。你认为学习更多的博弈论理论……天哪，在学术意义上学习更多的博弈论，超越那种肤浅的理解，你认为这对社会中实际发生的事情有好处吗？我认为，我认为高层概念是有好处的。换句话说，这种想法是，会有一群人提前一步思考，有些人会提前两步、三步、四步思考。而有趣的部分是试图弄清楚人口中有多少比例的人会提前思考那么多步。这样你就可以建立某种元系统。我觉得这可以转化为现实生活。
So in other words, the very high level concepts where you don't need to really understand a lot about information theory or anything, like the high level concepts, I would say yes. But they're also kind of like being developed as we speak so um no one has yet written like you know a layman's guide to this stuff so yeah probably unless you really want to geek out it's probably not the type of thing like you'd probably be better off reading the negotiation book but if you wanted to know if you ever wondered like why things remember i was talking about this earlier like why things cost what they do
换句话说，非常高层的概念，你不需要真正理解很多关于信息论之类的东西，高层概念，我会说是的。但它们也是在我们说话的同时被开发的，所以没有人写过这类东西的通俗指南。所以，是的，除非你真的想钻研，否则这可能不是那种类型的事情。你可能最好去读那本谈判书。但如果你想知道，如果你曾经想过为什么事情……记得我之前谈过这个，为什么事情的价格是那样的……
that's still this is actually kind of just a continuation of that fascination um and so uh i think this is a big part of that um and so if you're interested in economics maybe another way of putting it is if you're a machine learning person check this out because there's this whole field of economics that you need to catch up on and if you're an economist it's exactly the same but in reverse right fair enough so yeah all right on to the news yeah first news is a free book so i was just uh did you say free i did did. Free. And it's not even a Keynesian beauty contest. Everyone gets it for free. Annotated algorithms in Python. So I followed the programming subreddit and I came across this.
这实际上只是那种迷恋的延续。所以，我认为这是其中的很大一部分。所以如果你对经济学感兴趣，也许换一种说法是，如果你是一个机器学习人员，去看看这个，因为有整个经济学领域你需要赶上。如果你是经济学家，情况完全一样，但反过来，对吧？有道理。好的，新闻时间。是的，第一个新闻是一本免费的书。我刚才……你说免费？我说了。免费。而且它甚至不是凯恩斯选美竞赛。每个人都可以免费获得它。《Python 注释算法》。所以我关注了编程子版块，然后发现了这个。
It's pretty cool. I skimmed through the book. It has a lot of really interesting stuff. It's similar to, I have a book from Sedgwick called uh algorithms and c++ that i've had for you know super long time this is very similar in that it covers you know a lot of the same algorithms um and it you know the code is is documented and there's also you know you know paragraphs describing describing the solutions right in general i think python's a better language for kind of explaining things um so so this is probably
它很酷。我浏览了这本书。它有很多非常有趣的东西。它类似于我有一本 Sedgwick 写的《C++ 算法》，我已经用了很长时间了，这本书非常相似，因为它涵盖了许多相同的算法。而且代码有文档记录，还有描述解决方案的段落，对吧？总的来说，我认为 Python 是一种更好的解释事物的语言。所以这可能……
a better book than the one i have and it didn't cost a hundred dollars it's totally free so check it out you can get a pdf of it it's it's a long book i mean when they say it's a full book it is um 388 pages so uh it's the real deal um You could probably get a physical copy. I don't know how much that would cost, but it would be worth grabbing one of those. Otherwise, feel free to thumb through the PDF. It's totally free. Nice. My link is, oh, I mean, this is terrible, I guess, just having, this is not really a news story.
是一本比我那本更好的书，而且它不需要 100 美元，它是完全免费的。所以去看看吧，你可以得到它的 PDF。这是一本很长的书，我的意思是，当他们说这是一本完整的书时，它确实是……388 页。所以它是真材实料。你可能可以买到实体书。我不知道那要多少钱，但值得买一本。否则，随意翻阅 PDF。它是完全免费的。不错。我的链接是，哦，我的意思是，这太糟糕了，我想，只是有……这不是一个真正的新闻故事。
But this, if you type in, let's see if you type in interactive bloom filter maybe google can do it otherwise the link will be in the show notes but this is a little well you wouldn't call them a widget anymore like a applet but um and this is a javascript application demonstrating how a bloom filter works um but i thought it was two things one an interesting opportunity to mention to people about bloom filters um and a second thing i thought it was a pretty good thing so this is one at a website jason davies presumably by a person named jason davies um right and if you search interactive bloom filter it'll come up on google i think the second hit for me otherwise the link is in the show notes. And what a Bloom filter is,
但这个，如果你输入，让我们看看，如果你输入“交互式布隆过滤器”（interactive bloom filter），也许谷歌可以做到，否则链接会在节目说明中，但这是一个小……你不会再称它们为小部件了，而是小程序。这是一个演示布隆过滤器如何工作的 JavaScript 应用程序。但我认为这是两件事：一是向人们提及布隆过滤器的一个有趣机会；二是我想这是一个相当不错的东西。所以这是一个网站，Jason Davies，大概是由一个叫 Jason Davies 的人制作的。对吧？如果你搜索“交互式布隆过滤器”，它应该会出现在谷歌上，我想对我来说是第二个结果，否则链接在节目说明中。布隆过滤器是什么……
is if you think of a hash map, which is you have some array and you take some object that you want to put in the array and you hash it in some way and you put the object at the index in the array that was the result of your hash function so if you've never heard of hashing before that probably made no sense and if you never heard of hash mouse before it was probably not a great explanation but essentially you have a big list of places in your array and you put an object in somewhere in that list and then there are ways of handling things like collisions like what happens if two things can hash to the same result, especially if you imagine having only like two elements in your array,
如果你想到哈希映射（hash map），也就是你有一个数组，你把你想要放入数组的对象拿出来，以某种方式对它进行哈希处理，然后把对象放在数组中作为哈希函数结果的索引处。所以如果你从来没听说过哈希，那可能毫无意义；如果你从来没听说过哈希映射，那可能不是一个很好的解释。但本质上，你的数组里有一大堆位置，你把一个对象放在列表中的某个地方，然后有一些处理冲突的方法，比如如果两个东西哈希到同一个结果会发生什么，特别是如果你想象你的数组里只有两个元素，
even if you have a really great hash function, you still only have two results. So you're sort of modulizing whatever your result is down to only two. And so your chance of collision if you have one object in is you know 50 percent um and so what happens is that as the table gets more and more full you have to grow it because you need to make sure these collisions don't happen because they degrade your performance um and you limit how much stuff you can hold in memory so what if you want so so i've never seen a bloom filter before so i might totally
即使你有一个非常好的哈希函数，你也只有两个结果。所以你只是把你的结果模运算到只有两个。所以如果你有一个对象，冲突的几率是 50%。所以发生的情况是，随着表越来越满，你必须增加它，因为你需要确保这些冲突不会发生，因为它们会降低你的性能。而且你限制了内存中可以容纳的东西。那么如果你想要……所以我从来没见过布隆过滤器，所以我可能完全……
be embarrassing myself here but i think the idea correct me if i'm wrong is that you don't need to like actually look up a value so the difference between a bloom filter and a hash map is a hash map but don't spoil it no don't spoil it oh okay okay sorry i'm just figuring it out now so i'll let you finish okay sorry um not to interrupt you uh the but to interrupt you um so if you if you imagine you're building this hash map a lot of people have done this and this is great because it provides constant time lookup of your object right so now imagine if you had you know um a bunch of records in a database and say there was way too many to fit in memory but you still wanted to somehow keep track of which things were in your database so that you didn't have to perform the expensive database
在这里让自己出丑了，但我认为这个想法是，如果我错了请纠正我，你不需要真正查找一个值。所以布隆过滤器和哈希映射的区别在于哈希映射是……别剧透，不，别剧透。哦，好的，好的，抱歉，我正在弄清楚，所以我让你说完。好的，抱歉，不是要打断你，但是要打断你。所以如果你想象你在构建这个哈希映射，很多人都做过这个，这很好，因为它提供了对象的常数时间查找，对吧？现在想象一下，如果你在数据库中有一堆记录，假设它们太多了，无法放入内存，但你仍然想以某种方式跟踪哪些东西在你的数据库中，这样你就不必执行昂贵的数据库……
lookup just to see if something with a given id exists. And Bloom filters are the solution to that or a solution to that, which is to say, if you have, maybe you have, you know, a hundred million potential objects in your database and you don't know which ones
查找来查看具有给定 ID 的东西是否存在。而布隆过滤器是解决这个问题的方案，或者说是其中的一个方案，也就是说，如果你有，也许你有，你知道，数据库中有 1 亿个潜在对象，而你不知道哪些……
and it's, you know, cost you seconds to go over the network or to go to disk to read them out of the database. You're stuck with this simultaneous problem of it's expensive to check and it's too big to just hold all of the values in memory. And what a Bloom filter does is they take the items
而且，你知道，通过网络或去磁盘从数据库中读取它们需要几秒钟的时间。你陷入了这种同时存在的问题：检查成本很高，而且太大，无法将所有值都保存在内存中。而布隆过滤器所做的是，它们获取……
that you know are stored in your database, hash them, not once, but in three different ways. And there's kind of different ways of doing, producing three different hashes or however many different hashes or however many different hashes but producing multiple hashes and then setting a boolean flag and a bigger a big hash map there's just a boolean saying true or false and you just start hashing all of the items that exist on your disk and you just hash them into this this hash map and what happens is you will get collisions or you know it's very probably get collisions but you're not worried about it when someone comes in to say ask a question of the
你知道存储在数据库中的项目，对它们进行哈希处理，不是一次，而是以三种不同的方式。有不同的方法来产生三个不同的哈希，或者无论多少个不同的哈希，但产生多个哈希，然后在大的哈希映射中设置一个布尔标志，只是一个布尔值，说真或假，你只是开始对磁盘上存在的所有项目进行哈希处理，并将它们哈希到这个哈希映射中。发生的情况是，你会得到冲突，或者你知道，很可能会得到冲突，但当有人进来问问题时，你并不担心它……
thing that you're i guess this is sort of like a cache you know hey do you have object foo you hash object foo and if you have trues in the hash map for the three hashes of foo then what you can say is maybe but if you don't have three matching in this case three is the example they have here in this demo so i'm saying three but it doesn't have to be three but say you've hashed through three different ways and it didn't match you don't have those three entries and you in fact as long as if you're missing any one of them in your bloom filter then you go go, Oh, actually, I know for certain, I don't have that there. Because if you did have it, you would have those three entries in your Boolean map. And the reason you can only say maybe, if they're there is because you could have had collisions from multiple other different features that produce those
那个东西，我想这有点像缓存，你知道，“嘿，你有对象 foo 吗？”你对对象 foo 进行哈希处理，如果你的哈希映射中有 foo 的三个哈希的真值，那么你可以说“也许有”。但如果你没有三个匹配项（在这个例子中是三个，所以我在说三个，但不一定是三个），但假设你已经以三种不同的方式进行了哈希处理，而它没有匹配，你没有那三个条目，实际上，只要你的布隆过滤器中缺少其中任何一个，你就会想：“哦，实际上，我确定我没有那个。”因为如果你有它，你的布尔映射中就会有那三个条目。而你只能说“也许”的原因是，因为你可能从其他多个不同的特征中产生了冲突，这些特征产生了那些……
entries in the hash map. And so you don't know for sure, but based on the parameters of the hash map, sort of how many collisions happen, how many of the entries have the Boolean flag set, you can, you know, sort of a priori up front, you can know how likely if you say yes, is it to be true. And the more willing you are, that's see that the more willing you are that's awesome the more willing you are to accept false positives the more compact your bloom filter can be the
哈希映射中的条目。所以你不知道确定，但基于哈希映射的参数，比如发生了多少冲突，有多少条目设置了布尔标志，你可以，你知道，先验地，你可以知道如果你说“是”，它有多大可能是真的。你越愿意……那太棒了，你越愿意接受误报，你的布隆过滤器就可以越紧凑……
smaller memory footprint you need if you want it to be yep sorry oh yeah so the bloom filter in the example here is what like i think size of like 50 or something yeah i i would have to count it but on that order yeah so basically i uh i put in just three words i put cat dog and dart and uh um and then i just asked whether a was there and it said no because a hashed to three completely different cells than any of those words and i said aa and i said aa and by aa there was like one collision but then the other three were empty so it knew that aa couldn't be there and then i kept going and going and going i don't even know how many a's i'm up to probably 100 or 50 a's or something and it still has not even once been able to found one of these strings where all three of those cells are filled in it's pretty amazing right so
如果你想要它，你需要更小的内存占用。是的，抱歉。哦，是的，这里的例子中的布隆过滤器大小是多少？我想是 50 左右。是的，我得数一下，但大概是那个数量级。所以基本上，我输入了三个词：cat、dog 和 dart。然后我问“a”是否在那里，它说“没有”，因为“a”哈希到了三个与那些词完全不同的单元格。然后我输入了“aa”，它说“aa”，对于“aa”，有一个冲突，但另外三个是空的，所以它知道“aa”不可能在那里。然后我继续输入，我甚至不知道我输入了多少个“a”，可能是 100 个或 50 个“a”之类的，它仍然一次都没有找到这些字符串中所有三个单元格都被填满的情况。这太神奇了，对吧？所以……
you can find you know of course there exist bad cases so if you're talking about non sort of i don't i'm not going to get into the academic definition but if you're talking about like non-random queries like your queries have patterns like this can be much worse um but for just sort of like because you can basically you can you could get a collision on your very first try so if you imagine sort of cat and dog happen to hash to the same three values then then you're just screwed right even though you only tried twice that can't happen just the probability of it happening is low yeah i mean if you like assuming nothing about the hash function right like yeah the probability of that happening
你可以找到，你知道，当然存在坏情况。所以如果你谈论的是非学术定义，但我不会深入探讨学术定义，但如果你谈论的是非随机查询，比如你的查询有模式，这可能会更糟。但对于只是，因为你基本上可以，你可以在第一次尝试时就遇到冲突。所以如果你想象 cat 和 dog 碰巧哈希到相同的三个值，那么你就完蛋了，对吧？即使你只尝试了两次，那也不可能发生，只是发生的概率很低。是的，我的意思是，如果你假设哈希函数没有任何假设，对吧？是的，发生这种情况的概率……
is let's say there's 50 cells then it's it's uh what 47 1 over 47 times 46 or something like that but yeah it's extremely low but the more you'll notice if you play so usually everybody should check this out so if you don't know about bloom filters i've never had the opportunity to use one before but i always sort of keep them in the back of my mind that like, this would definitely be helpful if you ever needed it. Yeah, that seems awesome. And if you sort of play with the example, what you'll learn is the more things you put in the hash map, the more collisions you get, the more likely it is that
是，假设有 50 个单元格，那么它是……47 分之一乘以 46 分之一之类的。但是的，它极低。但你会注意到，如果你玩的话，通常每个人都应该看看这个。所以如果你不知道布隆过滤器，我以前从来没有机会使用过，但我总是把它们记在心里，觉得如果需要的话，这肯定会有帮助。是的，这看起来太棒了。如果你玩这个例子，你会学到的是，你放入哈希映射的东西越多，你得到的冲突就越多，你就越有可能……
when you query it, you'll get back a probably there. This is one of these things like, you know, I always am fascinated with just how unbelievably fast databases are. And this is probably one of the techniques that they use, right? I mean, it can be used for lots of things. Like I've seen it used a lot of distributed apps, you can imagine, want to do this kind of behavior because if you're making a request over the network that's very expensive and a high latency and so you'd rather much rather have it in memory but you can't sort of hold all the data in your memory that doesn't work one thing i noticed if you put in 13 z's um it only points to one cell i guess it's because the three different
当你查询它时，你会得到一个“可能在那里”。这是那种事情之一，你知道，我总是对数据库的速度快得令人难以置信感到着迷。这可能是他们使用的技术之一，对吧？我的意思是，它可以用于很多事情。比如我看到它在很多分布式应用中使用，你可以想象，想要这种行为，因为如果你通过网络发出请求，那是非常昂贵的，而且延迟很高，所以你宁愿把它放在内存中，但你不能把所有数据都保存在内存中，那行不通。我注意到一件事，如果你输入 13 个 z，它只指向一个单元格，我想是因为三个不同的……
hashes all have the same thing but i mean that's that was something very specific um but i think you could also for things in which a collision is low cost you could sort of also use this as your only data store so like imagine imagine saying like i want to don't want to pay a lot to, to keep track of all of the articles Jason has read on the New York times, not a promotion for the New York times website, but, but like every time that Jason has a cookie and I'm only allowed to store, you know, I have no idea if this is how cookies work, but, uh, let's just invent a fictitious scenario for now.
哈希都有相同的东西，但我的意思是，那是非常具体的。但我认为你也可以对于冲突成本低的事情，你可以把它当作你唯一的数据存储。所以，想象一下，说：“我不想花很多钱来跟踪 Jason 在《纽约时报》上阅读的所有文章。”不是为《纽约时报》网站做推广，但每次 Jason 有一个 cookie，而我只被允许存储……我不知道 cookie 是怎么工作的，但让我们先发明一个虚构的场景。
You know, if, if I want to store that uh in the or so not in the cookie but in the database back end for the new york times every time i saw jason's ip address or his cookie uh key like i i want to only you know allocate 64 bytes to holding jason's entry then every time he reads an article i could take the url of the article and put it in a bloom filter and just keep putting it in and putting it in. And over time, if I want to recommend him articles he's not yet read, I could consult the Bloom filter and say, has Jason read this article yet? Yes or no. And if it says probably yes, it's not very expensive to me because if I exclude it from my list, it's really not a big deal. It's not a bank, right? I'm just sort of like,
你知道，如果我想在《纽约时报》的数据库后端存储它，而不是在 cookie 中，每次我看到 Jason 的 IP 地址或他的 cookie 键，我只想分配 64 字节来保存 Jason 的条目，那么每次他阅读一篇文章，我都可以获取文章的 URL 并把它放入布隆过滤器，然后一直放进去。随着时间的推移，如果我想向他推荐他还没读过的文章，我可以咨询布隆过滤器并说：“Jason 读过这篇文章了吗？”是或否。如果它说“可能读过”，对我来说成本并不高，因为如果我把它从我的列表中排除，那真的没什么大不了的。它不是银行，对吧？我只是……
but the great news is there are many many many visitors to the new york times and i sort of know that i don't have to pay a huge cost or figure out like oh after a year i should delete my users because up front you're saying for a very compact representation i know i can hold this for all the users i'll ever encounter and know throughout all history all articles they've ever visited without having to, like, phase stuff out of the cache or not or whatever. Yeah, right, right. That's a great idea.
但好消息是《纽约时报》有很多很多访客，我知道我不必支付巨大的成本，也不必弄清楚，比如“一年后我应该删除我的用户”，因为你预先说，对于一个非常紧凑的表示，我知道我可以为我遇到的所有用户保存这个，并且知道历史上他们访问过的所有文章，而不必像从缓存中删除东西之类的。是的，对，对。那是个好主意。
In a sense, it's a little bit privacy-preserving too, although, you know, not quite. Oh, I don't know that it's primarily used for that purpose, but yeah, I can kind of see that. Yeah, I mean, it's loosely, I mean, it's a little bit more, it's more privacy-preserving but yeah you can kind of see that yeah i mean it's loosely i mean it's a little bit more it's it's more privacy preserving than just storing in plain text but yeah i wouldn't it's probably not cryptographically safe or whatever yeah but i'm and then you're right also lots of databases like key value stores and things things where you have
从某种意义上说，它也有点保护隐私，尽管，你知道，不完全是。哦，我不知道它主要用于那个目的，但是的，我可以看到这一点。是的，我的意思是，它松散地，我的意思是，它有点……它更保护隐私，但是的，你可以看到这一点。是的，我的意思是，它松散地，我的意思是，它有点……它比仅仅以纯文本存储更保护隐私，但是的，我不会……它可能不是加密安全的之类的。是的，而且你是对的，还有很多数据库，比如键值存储和那些你在内存缓存中有一些数据，在磁盘上有一些数据的东西，但你最终必须把东西踢出缓存，但你讨厌失去你知道它确实存在的事实。是的，对，对。是的，这太酷了。每个人都应该去这个 URL。有一件事，当我们在发布更新时，我确实包含了节目说明。所以如果你在 iTunes 上关注我们，节目说明应该在……或者在任何播客查看器上。节目说明应该在播客说明中。你只需点击……
some data in a cache in memory and some on disk but you you have to kick stuff out of the cache eventually but you sort of hate to lose the fact that you knew that that did exist. Yeah, right, right. Yeah, this is super cool. Everyone should go to this URL. One thing, I do include the show notes when we post the update. So if you follow us on iTunes, the show notes should be in the or on any podcast viewer. The show notes should be in the podcast notes. You just tap the
URL，它会直接带你到我们那一集的节目说明。然后你可以在说明中点击这个 URL 并转到布隆过滤器。每个人都应该去看看。它真的很酷。开车时不要这样做，但如果你在公共汽车上，或者你在家里，当你到家时，去看看这个布隆过滤器 JavaScript 的东西。它很酷。是的，我的新闻，第二个新闻是 OhMyZSH，它几乎是这个节目的工具。但是，你知道，把 ZSH 当作工具有点奇怪。但 OhMyZSH 非常棒。基本上，我不是那种人……
URL and it'll take you straight to our show notes for that episode. Then you could tap this URL in the notes and go to the Bloom filter. Everyone should check it out. It's really cool. Don't do it while you're driving, but if you're on a bus or something, or you're at home, when you get home, check out the, this Bloom Filter JavaScript thing. It's pretty cool. Yeah, my news, second news is OhMyZSH, which is almost a tool of the show. But, you know, it's kind of weird making ZSH a tool. But OhMyZSH is pretty awesome. Basically, I'm not one of these people
网址，它会直接带你进入该剧集的节目笔记。然后你可以点击笔记中的这个网址，跳转到布隆过滤器。每个人都应该去看看，真的很酷。开车时别看，但如果你在坐公交车或者在家时，到家后可以看看这个布隆过滤器JavaScript工具。它非常棒。是的，我的新闻，第二个新闻是OhMyZSH，它几乎成了本节目的常驻工具。不过，把ZSH当作工具确实有点奇怪。但OhMyZSH真的很棒。基本上，我不是那种人
that really cares that much about, let's say, Bash or ZSH or C-Shell. I feel like they're all more or less the same. But OhMyZSH adds a ton of functionality to ZSH. And I actually switched from
真正关心 Bash、ZSH 或 C-Shell 的人。我觉得它们大同小异。但 OhMyZSH 为 ZSH 增加了大量功能。我实际上就是因为这个才从
Bash to ZSH just because of this. So someone that I used to work with showed this to me. It does so many cool things. Like the tab completion is incredibly clever. If you put, let's say, the middle three characters of a directory when you're doing LS and you hit tab, it'll figure it out. There's a bunch of kind of of nice to haves like uh when you're inside of a github repository it tells you what branch you're on in the prompt um it colors a bunch of things like ls and things like that automatically um it uh yeah it has a ton of really awesome features
Bash 切换到了 ZSH。我以前的一位同事向我展示了这个工具。它能做很多很酷的事情。比如它的制表符补全功能非常聪明。如果你在执行 LS 时输入目录名的中间三个字符并按下 Tab 键，它就能识别出来。它还有很多不错的小功能，比如当你处于一个 GitHub 仓库中时，它会在提示符中告诉你当前所在的分支；它还会自动为 ls 等命令的输出着色；总之，它有很多非常棒的功能。
like uh um another really good one is uh it has a bunch of different themes so if you want kind of different color themes if you you know want like a prompt that's pretty easy on the eyes like a font color that's pretty easy on the eyes and that theme will kind of percolate into like all the other commands right so when you do ls you know it'll of fit that theme. So definitely check it out. The other thing is it'll do kind of this really cool tab completion. It'll actually, if you type in the name of a binary, and then you do like dash dash tab, it'll actually run that binary with dash dash help,
比如，另一个非常好的功能是它有许多不同的主题。如果你想要不同的配色方案，或者想要一个看起来比较护眼的提示符字体颜色，这个主题会应用到所有其他命令中。所以当你执行 ls 时，它也会符合那个主题。所以一定要去看看。另外，它还有一种非常酷的制表符补全功能。如果你输入一个二进制文件的名称，然后输入 -- 再按 Tab 键，它实际上会运行该二进制文件并加上 --help 参数，
and then it will try to extract the command line parameters, and then it'll autocomplete. Or if you do, you know, get dash dash, what's the example? And then it will try to extract the command line parameters. And then it will autocomplete. Or if you do git dash dash. What's the example? Or like git add dash dash b or something like that. It will resolve that to branch or something. So it will resolve command line parameters for you.
然后它会尝试提取命令行参数，并进行自动补全。或者如果你输入 git --，举个例子，它会尝试提取命令行参数，然后进行自动补全。或者像 git add --b 之类的。它会将其解析为 branch 或类似的东西。所以它会为你解析命令行参数。
It does all sorts of other cool stuff. I don't know if there's equivalents for other shells. Maybe there is, like an OhMyBash or some equivalent, right? But I guess the high-level thing here is check out these things. They're really powerful, and I feel like they've really increased my productivity pretty significantly. So OhMyZSH is literally a one-liner um i mean you have to change your your default shell to zsh and then you run this one line command and uh boom you have
它还有各种其他很酷的功能。我不知道其他 Shell 是否有类似的工具。也许有，比如 OhMyBash 之类的？但我认为这里的主要观点是去看看这些工具。它们非常强大，我觉得它们确实显著提高了我的工作效率。OhMyZSH 的安装简直就是一行命令，当然你得先把默认 Shell 改成 zsh，然后运行这一行命令，砰，你就拥有了
this whole thing um it also auto updates um which is kind of dangerous i think about it but uh yeah that does scare me i do use it but that also does scare me yeah i never really thought about the consequences there. I'm sure you can turn it off. You have to trust that they... Yeah, that's true. And then you have to trust that they know what they're doing otherwise. But yeah, I've been using it for a few months now, and I'm a big fan.
整个系统。它还会自动更新，虽然我觉得这有点危险，但确实让我有点害怕。我虽然在用，但确实也感到害怕。我从来没想过后果。我相信你可以关掉它。你必须信任他们……是的，没错。你必须信任他们知道自己在做什么。不过，我已经用了几个月了，我是它的忠实粉丝。
It's pretty cool. I guess I missed out because for news, is something I came across, but it's actually a legit actual tool, but it's not a software tool. I don't know. Maybe I should have been a tool of the show. So this is the Curta Calcul so i came across this through a weird sequence of events i had sort of known about it for a little while like in the back of my head i'd kind of seen it
这真的很酷。我想我之前错过了，因为关于新闻，这是我偶然发现的，但它实际上是一个合法的工具，不过不是软件工具。我不知道。也许我应该把它作为本期节目的推荐工具。这就是 Curta 计算器。我通过一系列奇怪的事件偶然发现了它，我脑海里隐约记得以前见过它。
um and then there were simultaneously i saw someone created a 3D printed version of this mechanical object. Ooh, nice. And then also Adam Savage, now that the guy from Mythbusters, they no longer do Mythbusters, has this channel on YouTube, Tested. And they covered this. The 3D printing thing that I had previously separately seen, the guy who 3D printed it printed one for Adam Savage that he unboxed on tested um and so that reminded
然后我同时看到有人制作了这个机械物体的 3D 打印版本。哦，不错。还有亚当·萨维奇（Adam Savage），就是《流言终结者》里的那个人，他们现在不做《流言终结者》了，他在 YouTube 上有一个频道叫 Tested。他们介绍了这个东西。我之前单独看到的那个 3D 打印版本，打印它的人给亚当·萨维奇也打印了一个，他在 Tested 节目里进行了开箱，这让我想起了它。
me about it anyways so the kurda calculator is also known as i think they call it the pepper mill calculator and this is a non-electronic calculator it just blows my mind thinking about it um and what you have is this tube that is maybe a couple inches in diameter you know i'm using we probably should use metric but i i i'm not it's not at hand uh do you want to estimate the metric size of it jason uh let me check okay anyways so something that is roughly about handheld and it looks sort of like a pepper mill uh And at the top, there's a little handle that you turn and grind just like you would. It is about five centimeters in diameter.
总之，Curta 计算器也被称为“胡椒磨计算器”。这是一种非电子计算器，想到这一点我就觉得不可思议。你拥有的是一个直径大约几英寸的管子（我应该用公制，但我手头没有……你想估算一下它的公制尺寸吗，杰森？让我查查。好吧，总之，它大约是手持大小，看起来有点像胡椒磨）。在顶部有一个小手柄，你可以像磨胡椒一样转动它。它的直径大约是五厘米。
Okay. And probably a little more than that long. And so what you have is a series of windows and displays, sliders and knobs that allow you to, on kind of one part of the two this is gonna be horrible you should check out the pictures but one part of the tube you sort of set you know kind of like the input for your calculation then on the top there's a set of displays that give you the output of your calculation and then through a sequence of kind of throwing some switches and turning the
好的。长度可能比那再长一点。你拥有的是一系列窗口、显示屏、滑块和旋钮，让你可以在管子的一部分上设置计算输入（这描述起来太糟糕了，你应该去看看图片），然后在顶部有一组显示屏，给出计算结果。通过一系列拨动开关和转动
the grinder crank uh you can perform multiplication multiplication division addition and subtraction um whoa cool on this calculator one of these still or no uh no no they stopped making them uh when they basically got devastated by tiny little you know pieces of silicon that did the same thing so early electronic calculators with like sort of discrete components and presumably even vacuum tubes and stuff were very expensive and fragile but then eventually you sort of had commoditized calculators and it put a ruin to these beautiful objects although these were popular all the way through the 1980s that's surprising um so check them out if you've never seen one before i think they're quite expensive to buy in working condition
研磨曲柄的操作，你可以在这个计算器上进行乘法、除法、加法和减法。哇，太酷了。现在还有这种计算器吗？不，不，他们停止生产了，因为他们基本上被那些能做同样事情的小硅片给摧毁了。早期的电子计算器，带有离散元件，甚至可能是真空管之类的，非常昂贵且脆弱，但后来计算器商品化了，这些美丽的物体就此终结。尽管它们在整个 20 世纪 80 年代都很流行，这真令人惊讶。所以如果你从未见过，一定要去看看。我觉得在能正常工作的情况下，买一个非常昂贵。
hundreds of dollars kind of thing and it's just fascinating to me and I don't think today we'd probably be like this is terribly slow but at the time being able to multiply I think it's like sort of 8, 9 digit numbers with sort of 11 digit running sum was incredible
要几百美元。这对我来说太迷人了。虽然今天我们可能会觉得它慢得要命，但在当时，能够进行 8、9 位数的乘法，并带有 11 位数的运行总和，简直是不可思议。
and to be able to do it pretty efficiently and so if you've never seen one of these before check it out to me with as a uh computer scientist by trade software engineer by trade um i'm always fascinated with intricate mechanical objects and this is sort of some sort of pinnacle of mechanical complexity uh the all the moving pieces the gears the fact that you're doing this we're going to talk about this it sort of goes along with cobalt in a way but doing decimal arithmetic where you sort of have like the number nine multiplied by the number seven and you need to be able to do that and display it in several different windows that have
而且能相当高效地完成。所以如果你从未见过，一定要去看看。对我来说，作为一个计算机科学家、软件工程师，我总是对复杂的机械物体着迷，这是机械复杂性的巅峰。所有的运动部件、齿轮，以及你正在做这件事的事实……我们要谈谈这个，它在某种程度上和 COBOL 有点像，但它是做十进制算术，比如数字 9 乘以数字 7，你需要能够做到这一点，并在几个不同的窗口中显示出来，这些窗口有
essentially 10 sided discs that you know pop into the right rotation when you it's just crazy it blows my mind like how do you even sit down and design start to design something like this i think it's one of these things where like you really have to have a good background in like number theory so actually i was playing a game so just to recap we did a few interview episodes and that's why now we have probably 10 tools of the show all in one show. But I was playing this game called Human Resource Machine. Did you play this? I have not.
本质上是 10 面的圆盘，当你操作时它们会跳到正确的旋转位置。这太疯狂了，让我大开眼界。你怎么能坐下来设计出这样的东西？我想这需要你有深厚的数论背景。顺便回顾一下，我们做了几次采访节目，这就是为什么现在我们有 10 个推荐工具。但我一直在玩一个叫《人力资源机器》（Human Resource Machine）的游戏。你玩过吗？我没有。
It's on my list of, like, I should buy this and play it. So, yeah, just for people who haven't heard about this game, basically you're given an assembler with very few instructions, and you have to complete different tasks, like sort a list or add one to every number that you can input. And the thing about this that's really cool is if you have a background in CS, if you have a bachelor's degree in CS even, you can blow through this game.
它在我的待办清单上，我想买来玩。对于没听说过这个游戏的人，基本上你会被赋予一个只有很少指令的汇编语言，你必须完成不同的任务，比如对列表进行排序，或者给输入的每个数字加 1。这个游戏最酷的地方在于，如果你有计算机科学背景，哪怕只是计算机科学学士学位，你也能轻松通关。
You'll know everything. If people don't have a background in CS, it's really cool because it kind of walks you through how to do all of these things using just a very few instructions and also it gives you an environment where you know there's a right answer um and but then it's got these challenge modes uh one of the challenge modes is do it in the fewest instructions possible um and that is really, really interesting. Another challenge mode is basically do it as quick as possible. So in other words, at runtime, you want to step through the fewest number of instructions.
你会知道一切。如果人们没有计算机科学背景，这也很酷，因为它会引导你如何仅使用极少数指令来完成所有这些事情。它还提供了一个环境，让你知道有一个正确答案。但它还有挑战模式，其中一个挑战模式是用最少的指令完成任务，这真的非常非常有趣。另一个挑战模式是尽可能快地完成。换句话说，在运行时，你希望通过最少的指令步数。
That's also really fun. But this is one of those things where if you have kind of a good background in number theory, you could probably figure out a way to do these multiplications using very few instructions and i feel like that's kind of necessary when you're when each instruction is like you know a physical thing that has to happen i want to know how you just make all of the sheer number of meshes meshing gears and cylinders and precisely engineered and it looks like it still cranks rather easily like that's crazy to me yeah are you gonna 3d print one so the 3d printed one is printed slightly bigger than the one i i really want to but i've found that my appetite for 3d printing things
这也很有趣。但如果你有很好的数论背景，你可能就能想出一种方法，用极少的指令进行这些乘法。我觉得当每个指令都是一个必须发生的物理动作时，这是必要的。我想知道你是怎么制造出这么多啮合的齿轮和圆柱体，而且工程如此精确，看起来还能转动得如此轻松，这对我来说太疯狂了。你会去 3D 打印一个吗？那个 3D 打印的版本比原版稍微大一点。我真的很想，但我发现我 3D 打印
with lots and lots of pieces is very low because i tend to get like halfway through so i recently tried to print uh this is off topic but they have a 3d printable transmission model with different gear ratios and so it's sort of like an automatic transit transmission except it doesn't automatically switch gears oh i guess just like a regular transmission not an automatic transmission oh got it anyways and i was like wow it's amazing so i like spent all this time printing it suffered a couple you know failed prints but eventually got it out of print and then realized i think it was not like i think it was not uh exactly square my printer or something at the time and so all the gears didn't mesh and like i had spent all this time printing it and then i think it wasn't quite right and i didn't know how to exactly how
有很多零件的东西的欲望很低，因为我往往打印到一半就……我最近尝试打印一个 3D 可打印的变速箱模型，有不同的齿轮比，它有点像自动变速箱，除了它不会自动换挡。哦，我猜就像普通变速箱，不是自动变速箱。哦，明白了。总之，我当时想，哇，太棒了。所以我花了很多时间打印它，经历了几次失败的打印，但最终打印出来了。然后意识到，我想当时我的打印机可能不太方正，所以所有的齿轮都无法啮合。我花了这么多时间打印，结果却不对，我也不知道该怎么
to fix it it wasn't obvious and it was just really frustrating to have spent all this time printing it, and then I think it wasn't quite right, and I didn't know exactly how to fix it. It wasn't obvious, and it was just really frustrating to have spent all that time, and then it wouldn't go together. That sounds terrible. Yeah, so I would love to print this. Like, in my mind, yes, I'll print this, but I don't know if I'll ever have. I would print the first three or four things and then be like, oh, I see how this works. I don't want to put the rest.
修复它。这并不明显，花那么多时间打印却无法组装起来，真的非常令人沮丧。听起来太糟糕了。是的，所以我很想打印这个。在我的脑海里，是的，我会打印这个，但我不知道我是否真的会。我可能会打印前三四个零件，然后就会想，哦，我明白它是怎么工作的了。我不想再装剩下的了。
Next. Cool, yeah, maybe I'll give it a shot i've been kind of itching for something to print but yeah i have a feeling well look at the assembly manual and uh sort of collaborate for the 3d printed one there's like a thingiverse um group or whatever where they discuss assembling it um i think there's only been a few other people to be able to do it besides the inventor. I think it's a pretty complicated thing. So check it out before committing to it. Okay, yeah, no.
下一个。酷，也许我会试一试。我一直很想打印点什么，但我有一种预感……好吧，看看组装手册，然后为那个 3D 打印版本协作一下。有一个 Thingiverse 小组之类的，他们在那里讨论组装它。我想除了发明者之外，只有少数几个人能做到。我觉得这是一个非常复杂的东西。所以在投入之前先去看看。好的，好的。
If it's not very simple to assemble, I generally am not very good at mechanical stuff. I mean, just look at the picture of how many parts there are inside of it if you Google Curta calculator. Anyways, it's not going to be easy. So I'm on Wikipedia, and yeah, it doesn't have a breakout of it, so I can't tell. It just looks complicated from the outside though.
如果组装起来不简单，我通常不太擅长机械方面的东西。我的意思是，如果你谷歌一下 Curta 计算器，看看里面有多少零件的图片就知道了。总之，这不会很容易。我在维基百科上查了一下，它没有拆解图，所以我看不出来。不过从外面看确实很复杂。
I'm sure if you search Curta calculator exploded, you will not want to print it anymore. You will find a 3D printer on fire. Yeah. Okay. Anyways. All right. So yeah, let's, we're falling a little bit behind, but we'll make this.
我敢肯定，如果你搜索“Curta calculator exploded”（Curta 计算器爆炸图），你就不想再打印它了。你会发现你的 3D 打印机都要着火了。好的。总之。好吧。我们有点落后了，但我们会赶上的。
Okay, here we go. We'll speed it up. But book of the show book, my book of the show is, uh, it's actually just a biography of Claude Shannon, who's a pretty famous mathematician. And I guess you could say computer scientist, although it was really kind of ahead of his time there. Um, but, uh, uh, but yeah, check it out. It's actually, I found this from a Medium blog that I follow.
好的，开始了。我们要加快速度。本期推荐的书籍，我的书是克劳德·香农（Claude Shannon）的传记，他是一位非常著名的数学家。我想你可以说他是计算机科学家，尽管他在那个时代确实非常超前。但，是的，去看看吧。我实际上是从我关注的一个 Medium 博客上发现的。
And it's actually the people who wrote the biography actually wrote a blog post talking about their process of, you know, because this is written posthumously, right? And so is that the right way to say it? Posthumously? Not humorously. I think it's pos-humorously? Not humorously. I think it's post-humorously. Post-humorously. Anyway, so they, after laughing, they decided to write this autobiography. And so, they covered, like, they actually went to his house.
写这本传记的人实际上写了一篇博客文章，谈论了他们的创作过程，因为这是在死后出版的，对吧？这是正确的说法吗？死后（Posthumously）？不是幽默地（Humorously）。我想是死后。总之，他们在笑过之后，决定写这本自传。所以，他们涵盖了……他们实际上去了他的家。
They did an unbelievable amount of research. Like, they're super passionate about Claude Shannon and these people. And they did a ton of research for years're super passionate about Claude Shannon these people and they did a ton of research for years and years and years um I haven't actually read the autobiography I just or the biography I just got it um but just reading the blog post I was already you know you put on my to-do list immediately because they it's an unbelievable effort and the other thing is Claude Shannon bucks the trend of sort of modern day success stories. You know, like, you know, they always say, oh, modern day people are organized. Modern day people are always going to the gym.
他们做了令人难以置信的研究。他们对克劳德·香农和这些人非常热情，他们做了多年的研究。我还没读过这本传记，我刚拿到它。但光是读那篇博客文章，我就已经把它放进我的待办清单了，因为这是一种令人难以置信的努力。另一件事是，克劳德·香农打破了现代成功故事的趋势。你知道，他们总是说，哦，现代人很有条理。现代人总是去健身房。
Modern day people are super hyper focused. And he kind of bucks all of that. Like he's not focused at all. He also abandons ideas and then comes back to them like 20 years later and so this guy's like like it sounds like he just has a limitless memory and and uh things are just incubating all the time and it's just an incredibly uncertain environment um um you know there's all of a sudden he's like oh something from 17 years ago now makes sense. And he just starts working on it and it's just completely chaotic, like totally risky, no plan. It just sounds kind of, it just completely goes against all. If you were to pick up like a, you know, a self-help book written by a CEO, this would
现代人超级专注。而他打破了所有这些。他一点也不专注。他还会放弃想法，然后在 20 年后又回到它们身边。所以这家伙听起来就像拥有无限的记忆力，事情一直在酝酿，而且环境非常不确定。突然间，他说，哦，17 年前的东西现在有意义了。然后他就开始研究它，这完全是混乱的，完全冒险，没有计划。这听起来完全违背了……如果你拿起一本 CEO 写的自助书，这会
go against everything. Um, but yet this person was insanely successful and i just find that fascinating also you know someone who's pretty disorganized like it kind of was sort of a ray of hope that people were kind of like cluttered and uh clutter minded uh still have a chance um but it's just cool to see to see this person just go about life like in a very different way i mean he'd like invent the bicycle like a new type of bicycle and then he'd like you know create this new kind of math equation and then he he so claude shannon's most famous thing is his work on entropy which is that's kind of ironic actually now that i think about it um but it's yeah like he came up with the information theory and entropy and the idea that, you know, let's say you have a long string, but it's all A, A, A, A, A.
违背一切。但这个人却极其成功，我发现这一点非常迷人。而且，作为一个相当杂乱无章的人，这给了我一丝希望，即那些杂乱无章的人仍然有机会。但看到这个人以一种非常不同的方式生活真是太酷了。我的意思是，他会发明自行车，一种新型自行车，然后他会创造这种新的数学方程。克劳德·香农最著名的是他在熵方面的工作，这实际上很讽刺，现在我想起来了。但他提出了信息论和熵，以及这个想法，你知道，假设你有一个很长的字符串，但它全是 A, A, A, A, A。
That's actually pretty simple. And even if you add more A's, it doesn't necessarily really become more complex. Right. That's that's a gross simplification of his work. But but, you know, he covered a lot of these, like what really is information? What is entropy? What is is complexity stuff like that um so yeah check out this book and it's it's not written for computer scientists so it's so anyone should be able to pick it up and read it um and i'm looking forward to uh to going through it his stuff comes up a lot in communication stuff if you ever do like networking yeah yeah you hear
这其实很简单。即使你添加更多的 A，它也不一定会变得更复杂。没错。这是对他工作的粗略简化。但是，你知道，他涵盖了许多这些问题，比如什么是信息？什么是熵？什么是复杂性之类的。所以，去看看这本书。它不是为计算机科学家写的，所以任何人都可以拿起来阅读。我很期待读完它。他的东西在通信领域出现得很多，如果你做网络相关的工作，你会听到
about stuff a fire upon the deep by verner vinci i feel like i already talked about this book but it's probably just because i read it a while ago and talked about it at work um so a fire upon the deep is i've heard i've had this recommended to me you know numerous times by various people it's uh been around for a while i think it was written in the nineties. And so it's not a new science fiction book, but it is part of what ultimately became a series, although I've only read this first book. And I, I, I think it's decently well-contained and it is sort of sci-fi from the level of um you know very uh alien concepts so uh in fact i actually had a little bit of trouble getting into the book initially um and just because of like how alien one of the sort of storylines in the book really is i try not to spoil things i won't spoil it um but basically
关于弗诺·文奇（Vernor Vinge）的《深渊上的火》（A Fire Upon the Deep）。我觉得我已经谈过这本书了，但这可能只是因为我很久以前读过它，并在工作中谈论过它。所以《深渊上的火》……我被不同的人多次推荐过这本书。它已经存在一段时间了，我想它是 90 年代写的。所以它不是一本新的科幻小说，但它是最终成为系列的一部分，尽管我只读了第一本。我认为它内容相当完整，而且它是一种非常外星概念的科幻小说。事实上，我最初读这本书时有点困难，只是因为书中的故事情节之一是多么的外星化。我尽量不剧透，我不会剧透的。但基本上
about people moving around in space and encountering alien species and some of the stuff that happens um and there's a lot of just like very strange things that happen um i sort of believe last this is kind of funny because i've read several books between but i had to pick one um but i think last time i talked about the three body problem and similarly had this thing like this is very sort of strange and different um And this book had a similar feel that things just feel foreign in them. And it's sort of an interesting part of reading science fiction. And maybe this is what I read the most. Maybe other forms of fiction also have similar things.
关于人们在太空中穿梭并遇到外星物种，以及发生的一些事情。有很多非常奇怪的事情发生。我相信上次……这很有趣，因为我在这之间读了几本书，但我必须选一本。但我认为上次我谈到了《三体》，它也有类似的东西，非常奇怪和不同。这本书也有类似的感觉，事情在其中感觉很陌生。这是阅读科幻小说的一个有趣的部分。也许这是我读得最多的。也许其他形式的小说也有类似的东西。
But just reading something that is talking about, you know, putting you in sort of the perspective of an alien that has nothing to do with you. That's just so dissimilar from humans. Obviously, it's still. That sounds like very tough to write yeah it is and and obviously like you know sort of bias because fundamentally they have some form of communication because the author still has to describe it um in some way and some pattern of thinking and in reality you know life could be very very different than that in these stories but it would be really hard to write from their perspective or whatever like writing from the perspective of a plant is or a tree would be super tricky um yeah right but anyway blah blah this is a side topic um this book is good i i don't probably give it like five out of five but a solid four out of five this
但阅读一些谈论……让你站在一个与你无关的外星人的角度。这与人类太不同了。显然，它仍然……这听起来很难写。是的，确实。显然，这有偏见，因为从根本上说，它们有某种交流形式，因为作者仍然必须以某种方式描述它，以及某种思维模式。实际上，生命可能与故事中的非常非常不同，但从它们的角度来写会非常困难。就像从植物或树的角度来写会非常棘手。是的，没错。但无论如何，这是题外话。这本书很好。我可能不会给它 5 分，但给个 4 分。
is a good read i thought it was really nice and i think it you know a lot of people this was a very uh important work to them they they really recommend it so it was definitely worth reading um it's definitely not what i would say is sort of light reading um it wasn't easy to sort of breeze through it was sort of tough and crunchy to get through but i enjoyed it so is this part of a series or no yes it is okay um the first one this is the first one yeah um i don't know much more about the rest so same thing as the three body problem is part of a series but i'm not sure this is always the tough thing about starting into series as you read the first book but you're kind of signed up that you knew it was a series you got to keep going because some of them just have like dramatic cliffhangers like they're really just one giant book split into three parts um fortunately for
这是一本好书。我觉得它真的很好，而且我认为很多人认为这是一部非常重要的作品，他们强烈推荐它，所以绝对值得一读。它绝对不是我所说的轻松读物。它不容易快速读完，读起来有点艰难和费劲，但我很喜欢。所以这是系列的一部分吗？是的。好的。这是第一本。是的。我不知道关于其余部分的更多信息。所以和《三体》一样是系列的一部分，但我不太确定。这就是开始系列书籍的难点，你读了第一本，但你有点像是签了名，你知道这是一个系列，你必须继续读下去，因为有些书就像是分成三部分的巨大书籍。幸运的是，对于
the three body problem and this one i don't really feel like that was the case like they didn't end on some giant nothing is wrapped up um but you could tell sort of where the next books would go yeah that makes sense so you're not signing up to have to read the whole series if you don't want yeah that's that's great this is uh a little bit off topic but remember well just in general i absolutely hate it when they set up like these huge cliffhanger endings um and especially when it's not great in the first place and you kind of know that it's this series isn't really going to even survive but then there's a cliffhanger so you don't get the closure at the end anyway you're talking about like tv series yeah yeah i was thinking about actually the super
《三体》和这一本，我并不觉得是这样。它们没有以某种巨大的悬念结束，没有什么是没交代清楚的。但你可以看出下一本书会走向哪里。是的，这很有道理。所以你不需要非得读完整个系列。是的，这太棒了。这有点题外话，但记住……总的来说，我非常讨厌他们设置那种巨大的悬念结局。尤其是当它本身并不出色时，你有点知道这个系列甚至不会存活下去，但还是有一个悬念，所以你最后还是得不到结局。你在谈论电视剧吗？是的，我实际上在想超级
mario brothers movie watching that when i was like eight years old and i was like even as an eight-year-old it's like this movie's kind of terrible and then they're like a you know bowser ran away it was like to be continued it's like nope nope oh man well so cool so uh if you like those books claude chanin i'm actually reading uh or i guess listening to on audible so um you can get an audible trial if you go to audibletrial.com slash programming throwdown and uh you could pick up the claude chanin book totally for free and uh also the fire on the deep is on audible oh nice i say read but i actually just listen to it i just say read because it's too confusing i think i'm gonna start doing that too yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna
马里奥兄弟电影。我八岁时看那部电影，即使作为一个八岁的小孩，我也觉得这部电影很糟糕，然后他们说“鲍泽逃跑了，未完待续”。就像，不，不。天哪。好吧，太酷了。所以，如果你喜欢那些书，克劳德·香农的书，我实际上正在读，或者说是在 Audible 上听。所以，如果你去 audibletrial.com/programmingthrowdown，你可以获得 Audible 试用，你可以免费获得克劳德·香农的书。而且《深渊上的火》也在 Audible 上。哦，不错。我说读，但我实际上只是听。我只是说读，因为我觉得太混乱了。我想我也要开始那样做了。是的，我要……
it's sort of weird but it's nobody's business that like like it's the same if you read or listen to an audiobook like and if you say i listen to this book people are going to be like what and you have to explain if you just say i read this book it's like yeah no yeah yeah i agree and i think it should just unless you say like i listened to and it was like a magazine or something with pictures like that would be weird but yeah right normal course i just say read uh you can also sponsor us on patreon uh the link is in the show notes or search programming throw down on patreon and thank you a shout out to all those people there's been an uptick in them all the people sponsoring us on Patreon so thank you for your continued support
这有点奇怪，但没人关心你是读还是听有声书。如果你说我听了这本书，人们会问“什么？”，你还得解释。如果你只是说我读了这本书，就像……是的，没错。我同意，除非你说“我听了”，而且那是一本杂志或带图片的什么东西，那会很奇怪。但正常的课程，我只是说读。你也可以在 Patreon 上赞助我们，链接在节目说明中，或者在 Patreon 上搜索 Programming Throwdown。感谢所有那些人，Patreon 上的赞助人数有所增加，所以感谢你们的持续支持。
yeah it's getting close to Christmas for Christmas we take the money that's left over that we haven't spent on trying to grow the show or trying to maintain our server or stuff like that and we give it in free t-shirts actually we've gotten a decent amount of Patreon subscribers so I think maybe what we'll do this year we'll still in free t-shirts. Actually, we've gotten a decent amount of Patreon subscribers.
是的，快到圣诞节了。对于圣诞节，我们会把剩下的钱，也就是我们没有花在试图发展节目或维护服务器之类的钱，拿出来捐赠。实际上，我们得到了相当多的 Patreon 订阅者，所以我想也许我们今年会……我们仍然会送免费 T 恤。实际上，我们得到了相当多的 Patreon 订阅者。
So I think maybe what we'll do this year, we'll still give some t-shirts and then we'll give the rest to charity. So if you have a cool charity, send us an email or post on the comments or something like that. I have my child's college fund. Patrick's P.W. Oh, the P.W. P.W. The Patrick Wheeler Personal Wealth Fund. the the the uh patrick's pw oh the pwpw the patrick wheeler personal wealth fund sorry that is a joke we will not be donating no that's not how that works we will not be donating to the pw squared tool of the show um tool this is my tool the show is topic my tool the show is bit, which is pretty cool, actually.
所以我认为也许我们今年会这样做，我们仍然会送一些 T 恤，然后把剩下的捐给慈善机构。所以如果你有一个很酷的慈善机构，给我们发电子邮件或在评论里留言之类的。我有我孩子的大学基金。帕特里克的 P.W. 哦，P.W. P.W. 帕特里克·惠勒个人财富基金。抱歉，那是个玩笑，我们不会捐赠的。不，不是那样运作的。我们不会捐给 PW 平方。本期推荐工具，工具……这是我的工具，本期节目是主题。我的推荐工具是 BitChute，其实很酷。
This is really fun. It's using something called WebTorrent, which people should also check out. But BitChute is like YouTube, but there's not really any server. So the way it works is when you go to upload a video, you can choose to serve your own video or not, right? And then what happens is when someone goes to watch, let's say, your video, they can actually get it from you or from anybody else who happens to be on BitChute and has a copy of your video. So as soon as one person watches your video,
这真的很有趣。它使用了一种叫 WebTorrent 的东西，人们也应该去看看。但 BitChute 就像 YouTube，但并没有真正的服务器。所以它的工作方式是，当你去上传视频时，你可以选择是否自己托管视频。然后，当有人去观看你的视频时，他们实际上可以从你那里，或者从任何恰好在 BitChute 上并拥有你视频副本的人那里获取。所以一旦有人观看了你的视频，
they then become a server as long as they're on the website. And so it's all done in JavaScript, like on the client side. So you're basically running BitTorrent, but on your browser. And if you go to WebTorrent, I think it's webtorrent.io or webtorrent.com, you can actually see a visualization of this. But even cooler, you just go to bit shoot and it just kind of feels like youtube but it does not feel like youtube i just went what do you mean i mean it feels like in the sense that there's a bunch of videos that you can watch yes um i don't know i mean and there's no search i guess is there no but also just like the sort of like i don't know. I mean, there's no search, I guess, is there? No, but also just like the sort of like, I don't know, I guess maybe because I go to YouTube so much, it's now curated to my tastes. But I don't know what generic YouTube is.
只要他们还在网站上，他们就变成了服务器。所以这一切都是用 JavaScript 完成的，在客户端。所以你基本上是在浏览器上运行 BitTorrent。如果你去 WebTorrent，我想是 webtorrent.io 或 webtorrent.com，你实际上可以看到这个的可视化。但更酷的是，你只需去 BitChute，它感觉就像 YouTube，但它感觉不像 YouTube。我刚才去了。你是什么意思？我的意思是，它感觉就像有很多视频可以看。是的。我不知道，我的意思是，没有搜索功能，对吧？没有，但也只是那种……我不知道。我的意思是，也许是因为我经常去 YouTube，它现在是根据我的口味策划的。但我不知道通用的 YouTube 是什么样的。
But the production value of generic front page YouTube videos is generally pretty good. Yeah, actually, you hit the nail head. I should preface this by saying this is like looks like stuff people would be stuff people would be – people would get takedown notices from YouTube for. Yeah, yeah. That's actually a really good point. This is like – I found this to be a tool to show because it's kind of a cool technology. Okay. Like I just – like I found it was cool that like functionally it's just like a bunch of videos,
但通用 YouTube 首页视频的制作质量通常相当不错。是的，实际上你一针见血。我应该先说明一下，这看起来像是人们会……人们会收到 YouTube 的下架通知的东西。是的，没错。这实际上是一个很好的观点。我发现这是一个值得推荐的工具，因为它是一种很酷的技术。好的。就像我发现它很酷，因为功能上它就像一堆视频，
but it's like running off like maybe one machine on AWS or something. Like the idea that like there's not really a backend for this. But you're right. And I guess it's a tool in the sense that you could upload a video and give that link to a bunch of people. And I guess presumably it would work. Although I guess your machine also has to be. That's a great tool.
但它是在 AWS 上的一台机器上运行的。就像没有真正的后端一样。但你是对的。我想它是一个工具，因为你可以上传一个视频并把那个链接给一群人。我想大概它会起作用。虽然我想你的机器也必须是……那是一个很棒的工具。
I don't know. Yeah, this is actually a terrible tool. My real tool this show is OhMyZSH, and this should be my news. But anyway, I just thought this was really cool. I mean, I didn't really think it was possible to have BitTorrent running in your browser. I thought that's, like, you know, I didn't really, like, I don't even really understand. I mean, you know, I'm definitely not a web developer, you know, expert or anything. But I don't really understand how you can make connections to other people in the browser, like besides the server.
我不知道。是的，这实际上是一个糟糕的工具。我本期真正的工具是 OhMyZSH，这应该是我的新闻。但无论如何，我只是觉得这真的很酷。我的意思是，我真的没想到可以在浏览器中运行 BitTorrent。我以为那是……你知道，我甚至真的不明白。我的意思是，你知道，我绝对不是 Web 开发专家之类的。但我真的不明白你怎么能在浏览器中与其他人建立连接，除了服务器之外。
I just figured there was just a fundamental rule that you could not do that. That seems like something that could be abused or something. But, I mean, this is living proof that not only can you do that, but these people have built basically the functionality of YouTube without actually holding any of the videos, which is pretty wild. We should also say we probably don't endorse any of the videos that are on this. Oh, yeah, yeah. Because most of these seem very conspiracy theory. Actually, you know what?
我只是认为有一个基本规则，你不能那样做。这看起来像是可能被滥用的东西。但是，我的意思是，这是活生生的证明，不仅可以做到这一点，而且这些人基本上构建了 YouTube 的功能，而没有实际持有任何视频，这非常疯狂。我们也应该说，我们可能不认可上面的任何视频。哦，是的，是的。因为大多数看起来非常像阴谋论。实际上，你知道吗？
Here's what I'm going to do. In the show notes, I'm actually going to put WebTorrent and not this site okay i actually know nothing about this site i only was linked to it from web torrent i see so my new tool of the show is web torrent you can go to web torrent.io and it actually when you go to web torrent.io, it starts playing a video and you can actually, but on the left, you can actually see you connecting to these other random people and them actually giving you the video. So yeah, go there instead. But it's pretty wild. Yeah.
我要这样做。在节目说明中，我实际上会放 WebTorrent，而不是这个网站。好的，我对这个网站一无所知，我只是从 WebTorrent 链接到它的。我明白了。所以我的新推荐工具是 WebTorrent。你可以去 webtorrent.io，当你去 webtorrent.io 时，它就开始播放视频，你实际上……但在左边，你实际上可以看到你连接到这些其他随机的人，他们实际上在给你视频。所以，去那里吧。但这很疯狂。是的。
All right. Yeah. I mean, that is cool. That's crazy. Yeah. I just want to give that preface that like we can't vouch for the content on that website. Yeah. I just, I scrolled through some of it and it's it's pretty weird so yeah let's so yeah we're uh we're not gonna make that up all right my tool of the show is a gadget on ios by korg although i also saw
好的。是的。我的意思是，那很酷。太疯狂了。是的。我只是想先说明一下，我们不能为那个网站上的内容担保。是的。我只是浏览了一些，它非常奇怪。所以，是的，让我们……所以，是的，我们不会编造那个。好的，我的推荐工具是 Korg 在 iOS 上的 Gadget，虽然我也看到
they released this on mac this week sorry uh android and linux and windows people uh that's basically sorry everyone um but this is so also i'm warning this is very it is expensive but it does go on sale and um for the kind of thing it is like you can do this is a music app um where there's a bunch of synthesizers and a sequencer and tracks and you can do even audio recording if you want. There's really sort of like a powerful tool. And if you go and listen to some of the music people are producing on this app, it's just absolutely astonishing. But for me, I don't know.
他们本周在 Mac 上发布了这个。抱歉，Android、Linux 和 Windows 的用户，那基本上……抱歉大家。但这……我也要警告，它很贵，但它确实会打折。对于这种东西，它是一个音乐应用程序，有很多合成器、音序器和轨道，如果你想的话，甚至可以进行音频录制。它确实是一个强大的工具。如果你去听听人们在这个应用程序上制作的一些音乐，简直令人震惊。但对我来说，我不知道。
I have this weird, like I wish I was a musician, but I'm not. But I also don't have the discipline to teach myself an instrument. Okay. And so I like to play it being a musician. Like I have this idea it would be cool to have like, you know, a piano in the house. But then I'm going to have this giant piano and I don't know how to play. And I know I won't learn how to play. I'm a terrible person.
我有一种奇怪的感觉，我希望我是一个音乐家，但我不是。但我也没有纪律去自学乐器。好的。所以我喜欢假装自己是音乐家。我有一个想法，家里有一架钢琴会很酷。但后来我会有这架巨大的钢琴，但我不知道怎么弹。而且我知道我不会学怎么弹。我是一个糟糕的人。
Anyways. It's probably a huge learning. I mean, I'm the same way. I don't know any instruments. But I imagine it takes an extraordinary amount of time to learn how to play something so i have tried i mean i took piano lessons when i was younger um and i ran into some problems that i just don't like i didn't have good rhythm and i didn't sort of stay diligent enough or you know maybe if there had been youtube it would have been more engaging at the time
总之。这可能是一个巨大的学习过程。我的意思是，我和你一样。我不会任何乐器。但我可以想象，学习弹奏某种东西需要花费大量的时间。所以我尝试过，我的意思是，我年轻时上过钢琴课，但我遇到了一些问题，我没有很好的节奏感，而且我没有足够勤奋，或者你知道，如果当时有 YouTube，它可能会更吸引人。
um but but anyways it doesn't matter. So this all started because I have this weird thing about synthesizers. I just love the way synthesizers work. And the way that I love the Curta calculator is this mechanical object. Oh, that makes sense. These analog synthesizers, they're just these boxes full of knobs and plugs. And especially if you don't know about modular synthesizers, specifically Eurorack modular synthesizers,
但无论如何，这不重要。所以这一切开始是因为我对合成器有一种奇怪的感觉。我只是喜欢合成器的工作方式。我喜欢 Curta 计算器的方式就是这种机械物体。哦，那说得通。这些模拟合成器，它们只是装满旋钮和插头的盒子。特别是如果你不知道模块化合成器，特别是 Eurorack 模块化合成器，
check it out. There are basically these panels that mount in a wall and you take quarter inch instrument jacks, sort of like fat headphone jacks, and you plug them in between all these different modules. It's literally plug and play. And one might make random voltages going up and down and another you know has knobs for a filter and you have all these different things and you
去看看。基本上有这些安装在墙上的面板，你拿四分之一英寸的乐器插孔，有点像粗的耳机插孔，然后把它们插在所有这些不同的模块之间。它真的是即插即用。一个可能会产生随机的电压上下波动，另一个你知道有滤波器的旋钮，你有所有这些不同的东西，然后你
end up making sounds like weird sounds cool sounds sounds that sound like instruments it just all these various things uh anyways i just i just think and specifically i wanted my tool of the show to be the the pocket operator uh which is by teenage engineering which is something that is like a pcb that looks just like uh and we talked about credit calculators i guess it kind of goes with it but it looks like a calculator but it actually is this sort of toy but also really cool um synthesizer that is uh it's still a little expensive for what it is but you know for these kinds of things it's not very expensive and it has these buttons that you push and if you listen to the audio demos it just makes these cool sounds and it seems like something that people kind of just play with and make these cool sounds i know if i play with it would be kind of
最终发出声音，像奇怪的声音、酷的声音、听起来像乐器的声音，所有这些各种各样的东西。总之，我只是……我只是认为，我特别希望我的推荐工具是 Teenage Engineering 的 Pocket Operator，它是一个看起来像 PCB 的东西，就像……我们谈到了计算器，我想它有点配套，但它看起来像一个计算器，但它实际上是这种玩具，但也非常酷的合成器。它对于它本身来说还是有点贵，但你知道，对于这类东西，它不是很贵。它有这些你按的按钮，如果你听音频演示，它只是发出这些酷的声音，看起来像是人们只是玩玩，然后做出这些酷的声音。我知道如果我玩它，会有点……
loop it terrible that's right you know loop it and you know make you know change if it goes or um you know and play sort of notes on it uh all these different things and they also make other things this teenage engineering check them out but that was couldn't be the tool of the show because it's a physical thing and i wanted to have a piece of software so i have this core gadget you can play around on which is what i do or make serious music if you're into that kind of thing, check it out. It's kind of cool what people are doing. Yeah, I actually have the iCorg. Yeah, sure.
循环播放，没错，你知道循环播放，然后你知道如果它运行或者嗯，你知道，在上面演奏各种音符，所有这些不同的东西，他们也制作其他东西，这个 Teenage Engineering，去看看他们，但那不可能是本期的工具，因为它是一个实物，而我想要一个软件，所以我有了这个 Korg Gadget，你可以在上面玩，这就是我所做的，或者如果你喜欢那种东西，可以制作严肃的音乐，去看看吧。人们正在做的事情真的很酷。是的，我实际上有 iKorg。是的，当然。
Which is a different app. It's probably a simpler version. But very, very similar. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. It's super fun. It was a little expensive. I think it's like $20 on the App Store, which is, you know, a lot for an app.
这是一个不同的应用程序。它可能是一个更简单的版本。但非常、非常相似。是的，是的。是的，是的。它超级有趣。它有点贵。我想在 App Store 上大约是 20 美元，你知道，对于一个应用程序来说这很多。
Yes. But yeah, I actually made some MP3s that like, I mean, it's like, you know a lot for an app yes but uh uh but yeah i actually made some mp3s that like i mean it's like you know uh again like techno music made by someone who has no talent so it sounds good to you and your mom would say well is that what you kids are into these days um yeah exactly so yeah so similar to what i my experience i think this is 40 not on sale occasionally it goes on sale to 20 um but yeah i i play around with every so often um and pretend that i know how to make music and it's cool yeah and you can actually save an mp3 and send it to your friends and stuff like that and i would never do that but but you might i mean if you make some awesome music feel free
是的。但是，是的，我实际上制作了一些 MP3，就像，我的意思是，就像，你知道对于一个应用程序来说这很多，是的，但是嗯，但是是的，我实际上制作了一些 MP3，就像，我的意思是，就像，你知道，再次像是一个没有天赋的人制作的电子音乐，所以它听起来对你和你妈妈来说很好，她会说，这就是你们这些孩子现在喜欢的东西吗？嗯，是的，完全正确，所以是的，所以和我之前的经历很相似，我想这是 40 美元，没打折，偶尔会打折到 20 美元，但是是的，我偶尔会玩一下，假装我知道怎么制作音乐，这很酷，是的，你实际上可以保存一个 MP3 并发送给你的朋友之类的，我永远不会那样做，但你可能会，我的意思是，如果你制作了一些很棒的音乐，请随意
to send it our way i'm happy to listen to your music which is probably better yeah let's have like a contest let's see whoever makes the coolest mp3 um and and and links it to us like either soundcloud or email us the mp3 or something um we can maybe make it the intro of the next show or at least the outro because if we get all terrible results we'll pick the least terrible and put it as the outro we'll commit to it we'll commit we'll definitely make it something um we could probably make it the intro some people out there have got to be good musicians someone's gonna send us something awesome and then i'm just gonna feel terrible about myself no if someone sends us something awesome we will just replace our intro like permanently um but uh we have a pretty cool intro the bnr pilot is pretty awesome so it's gonna be tough it's been good for six years yeah it's been going forever but yeah maybe it's time for a change so yeah someone uh
发送给我们，我很乐意听你的音乐，这可能更好，是的，让我们来一场比赛，看看谁制作了最酷的 MP3，然后链接给我们，比如 SoundCloud 或者通过电子邮件发送 MP3 给我们之类的，我们也许可以把它作为下一期的片头，或者至少是片尾，因为如果我们得到的结果都很糟糕，我们会选出最不糟糕的一个作为片尾，我们会承诺这样做，我们会承诺，我们一定会把它变成某种东西，我们可能可以把它作为片头，外面肯定有一些优秀的音乐家，有人会给我们发送一些很棒的东西，然后我就会对自己感觉很糟糕，不，如果有人给我们发送了一些很棒的东西，我们就会永久替换我们的片头，但是，我们有一个相当酷的片头，Binar Pilot 的那个非常棒，所以这会很难，它已经用了六年了，是的，它已经用了很久了，但也许是时候做出改变了，所以是的，有人
try sending it send us some cool intro music and uh and change programming throw down forever that's true yeah leave your mark on the show all right um cool after after all that cobalt we have to go fast cobal mainframes. We'll kind of jump through this. So yeah, so COBOL. So basically, COBOL is fascinating. It's used by so many people, even today. It actually started as an initiative through the Department of Defense and kind of a consortium of companies. And, uh, the reason to create COBOL was that,
尝试发送它，发送给我们一些很酷的片头音乐，然后改变 Programming Throwdown 永远，这是真的，是的，在节目中留下你的印记，好的，嗯，酷，在所有这些 COBOL 之后，我们必须快点，COBOL 大型机。我们将跳过这一部分。所以是的，所以 COBOL。所以基本上，COBOL 很迷人。它被很多人使用，即使在今天。它实际上是作为国防部和一系列公司财团的一项倡议开始的。而且，嗯，创建 COBOL 的原因是，
uh, you know, it was that time where people were sort of inventing a lot of languages, right. Um, um, you, you kind of see this actually,
嗯，你知道，那是人们正在发明很多语言的时代，对吧。嗯，嗯，你，你实际上有点看到这一点，
this has gone, this has happened multiple times and it's almost a happening again right now, or maybe a couple of years ago where memory, how like all of a sudden we had TypeScript and we had CoffeeScript and we had like 10 different way closure script we had all these different ways to basically write JavaScript or that would somehow compile to Java transpile to JavaScript right so this is the same kind of thing right right? This, you know, in the, in the 60s, maybe even earlier in the 50s, it's an explosion of languages, right? I mean, it's Fortran 57,
这已经发生了，这已经发生过多次，而且现在几乎又在发生，或者也许是几年前，内存，就像突然之间我们有了 TypeScript，我们有了 CoffeeScript，我们有了 10 种不同的方式，ClosureScript，我们有所有这些不同的方式来基本上编写 JavaScript，或者以某种方式编译成 Java，转译成 JavaScript，对吧，所以这是同样的事情，对吧？这，你知道，在 60 年代，甚至可能更早的 50 年代，这是一个语言的爆炸，对吧？我的意思是，那是 Fortran 57，
you know, Lisp was coming out around that time. A ton of languages were being invented. And, and the issue is it was costing, the other thing is these languages were being built for specific machines. It's like, you know, if you want to use this machine, you have to write everything in, you know, Fortran 57. And it's like, oh, you know, I wanted to buy the latest machine, but that machine requires me to write everything in Lisp.
你知道，Lisp 大约在那个时候出现。大量的语言正在被发明。而且，问题是它正在花费，另一件事是这些语言是为特定的机器构建的。就像，你知道，如果你想使用这台机器，你必须用，你知道，Fortran 57 编写所有东西。就像，哦，你知道，我想买最新的机器，但那台机器要求我用 Lisp 编写所有东西。
And it's like a huge undertaking, right? So, these people got together and they decided to make sort of... they felt like if they got enough all these big players at the time like ge phillips ibm and the government you know department of defense etc that they would just make the ultimate programming language and it would be done and people could just write in cobalt and they'd never have to rewrite it again obviously that hypothesis was completely busted.
这就像一项巨大的工程，对吧？所以，这些人聚在一起，他们决定制造某种……他们觉得如果他们召集了当时所有这些大玩家，比如 GE、飞利浦、IBM 和政府，你知道国防部等等，他们就会制造出终极编程语言，它就会完成，人们可以只用 COBOL 编写，他们永远不必再重写它，显然那个假设完全破灭了。
I mean, in hindsight, I mean, you look at today, there's JavaScript, there's C++, there's Java, there's Python. So this idea of one language to unify them all didn't really pan out. But at the time, you know, that was a perfectly rational hypothesis. I mean, it only makes sense in hindsight, right, that that isn't the right thing to do. And so they made COBOL. Actually, as of 2012, which is the latest data I could get, over 60% of organizations are still dependent on COBOL to some degree,
我的意思是，事后看来，我的意思是，你看看今天，有 JavaScript，有 C++，有 Java，有 Python。所以这种统一所有语言的想法并没有真正实现。但在当时，你知道，那是一个完全合理的假设。我的意思是，事后看来这才有意义，对吧，那不是正确的事情。所以他们制造了 COBOL。实际上，截至 2012 年，这是我能得到的最新数据，超过 60% 的组织在某种程度上仍然依赖 COBOL，
which is enormous. I mean, if you go and work for a company, let's say a large company, that it's more likely than not that you will have to see some COBOL. Not that you will have to see, but that the company you're at has to. That's true. Yeah, that's true.
这非常巨大。我的意思是，如果你去一家公司工作，比如说一家大公司，你很有可能会看到一些 COBOL。不是说你必须看到，而是你所在的公司必须看到。这是真的。是的，这是真的。
It's mainly used for financial services. I know in a previous job, there was somebody who had to interface with uh like a credit card um company so basically like let's say you have your credit card it's capital one or you have a chase card you have the amazon card or what have you um there's a lot of different sort of let's say brands but there's there's really like three or four kind of let's say back ends so in other words you might have a capital one card but it's really visa right um so there's someone who had to interface with i think it was either
它主要用于金融服务。我知道在之前的一份工作中，有人必须与像信用卡公司之类的进行接口，所以基本上，比如说你有你的信用卡，它是 Capital One，或者你有 Chase 卡，你有亚马逊卡等等，嗯，有很多不同种类的品牌，但实际上只有三四个后端，所以换句话说，你可能有一张 Capital One 卡，但它实际上是 Visa，对吧，所以有人必须与我想是
visa or mastercard one of these and um um and it was all in cobalt now this was they had a they had a specification so you know on our side we didn't have to write cobalt but looking at the specification it was obvious that the people on the other side that it was all COBOL um you know everything was fixed with text and stuff like that um just like you know column zero through ten are going to be the name of the account and stuff like that um another really kind of interesting footnote in COBOL is is uh COBOL was like ground zero for the y2k problem um now this was i guess 17 years ago so there might be people listening to this actually there's definitely
Visa 或 Mastercard 其中之一进行接口，而且，而且它全部是用 COBOL 编写的，现在这是他们有一个规范，所以你知道在我们这边，我们不必编写 COBOL，但查看规范，很明显另一边的人，它全部是 COBOL，你知道所有东西都是固定文本之类的，就像你知道第 0 到 10 列将是账户名称之类的，嗯，COBOL 中另一个非常有趣的脚注是，COBOL 是 Y2K 问题的零点，现在这大概是 17 年前的事了，所以可能有人在听这个，实际上肯定有
people listening to show who weren't even born when the y2k project was a problem wow yeah dude way to way to bring it home but for people who don't know or don't remember, you know, in the year 2000, there was a big problem with computers, which is computers up until then, many of them had been using two digits to represent the date. So imagine, you know, your bank, every day they're calculating interest and they're giving you, you know, a fraction of a penny every day. And at some point it becomes a penny and you get an extra penny in your savings account. Now, all of a sudden, it goes from December 31st of 1999, or let's say 99, to January 1st of 00. So if you only use two digits to represent the day, what that means is you just went back 100 years back in time.
听节目的人在 Y2K 项目成为问题时甚至还没出生，哇，是的，伙计，真会总结，但对于那些不知道或不记得的人，你知道，在 2000 年，计算机出现了一个大问题，那就是在那之前的计算机，许多一直在使用两位数字来表示日期。所以想象一下，你知道，你的银行，每天他们都在计算利息，他们每天给你，你知道，一分钱的一小部分。在某个时候它变成了一分钱，你的储蓄账户里多了一分钱。现在，突然之间，它从 1999 年 12 月 31 日，或者说是 99 年，变成了 00 年 1 月 1 日。所以如果你只用两位数字来表示日期，这意味着你刚刚回到了 100 年前。
And so that same bank that's giving you, you know, a tiny bit of a penny every day, all of a sudden they just drain your bank account. Like they're like, you know, you made, you know, negative half a penny of interest, you know, for, you know, 100 years. And so, you know, you had, you had a $500 in your bank account and it's gone. Right. And so the Y2K problem was this belief that there's so many computers, all of them are using two digits for the year that, you know, even if one of them isn't updated or some program isn't updated, it's just going to cause total havoc, right? And COBOL, because, you know, and we'll get to this, there's like, COBOL, like, you know, the number of decimals is kind of intrinsic to the language. And so many COBOL programs have been written assigning just two numbers for the year,
所以那家每天给你，你知道，一点点利息的银行，突然之间他们就清空了你的银行账户。就像他们说，你知道，你赚了，你知道，负半便士的利息，你知道，持续了，你知道，100 年。所以，你知道，你的银行账户里有 500 美元，它没了。对。所以 Y2K 问题是这种信念，即有太多的计算机，它们都在使用两位数字表示年份，以至于，你知道，即使其中一个没有更新，或者某个程序没有更新，它也会造成彻底的混乱，对吧？而 COBOL，因为，你知道，我们会谈到这一点，有像，COBOL，就像，你知道，小数位数在语言中是内在的。所以许多 COBOL 程序被编写为只为年份分配两个数字，
that COBOL was a big part of the Y2K problem. And it required a massive amount of work to, you know, get everyone on a four digit year in time. And the long story short, just to finish it off, you know, everyone fixed, all the major stuff was fixed. I don't honestly even know of one thing that went wrong that was in any way significant um that i remember and uh yeah just basically nothing happened but you know it nothing happened because of an extraordinary amount of effort went in you know before the year 2000 to make that fix so the basic functions of cobalt are that it has procedures You do compile it as opposed to it being interpreted. And that it's statically typed for objects,
COBOL 是 Y2K 问题的重要组成部分。它需要大量的努力来，你知道，让每个人及时使用四位数的年份。长话短说，总结一下，你知道，每个人都修复了，所有主要的东西都修复了。我老实说甚至不知道有什么重要的事情出了差错，我记得的，而且，是的，基本上什么也没发生，但你知道，什么也没发生是因为在 2000 年之前投入了巨大的努力来完成那个修复，所以 COBOL 的基本功能是它有过程，你确实编译它，而不是解释它。而且它是静态类型的对象，
but the perimeters themselves are just duck types. So, I mean, to be fair, I guess this set of things is not that much different from most of the languages we use today. But, yeah. Yeah, I mean, the only big difference is if you pass a number into a function that takes a string, it'll convert it to a string for you and vice versa. That's kind of unique. Actually, I can't really think of any language that does that.
但参数本身只是鸭子类型。所以，我的意思是，公平地说，我想这组东西与我们今天使用的大多数语言并没有太大区别。但是，是的。是的，我的意思是，唯一的巨大区别是如果你把一个数字传给一个接受字符串的函数，它会为你把它转换成字符串，反之亦然。这有点独特。实际上，我真的想不出任何做这种事的语言。
Yeah, I guess that's true. Yeah, now that I think about it. That is pretty special. Feature or bug, you decide. Yeah, sure. I feel like actually that's probably more harm than good. But yeah, it's definitely unique. Another unique feature is this idea called picture clauses,
是的，我想那是真的。是的，现在我想起来了。那确实很特别。功能还是 Bug，你决定。是的，当然。我觉得实际上这可能弊大于利。但是的，它绝对是独特的。另一个独特的功能是这个叫做图片子句的想法，
which somehow like kind of combines classes with S per an F. So it's sort of like you basically say, you know, I want to take in a string and I want to, you know, kind of whenever a string enters this function, it comes out, let's say, formatted as a date. But instead of calling sprintf every time you want to do that, it's sort of this object that kind of holds the string, you know, in this new state for you. And it's kind of, you can kind of, you know, pass that sort of like this date converted string. You can pass that around to different functions
它以某种方式结合了类和 Sprintf。所以它有点像你基本上说，你知道，我想接收一个字符串，我想，你知道，每当一个字符串进入这个函数时，它出来时，比如说，格式化为日期。但不是每次你想这样做时都调用 sprintf，它是一种持有字符串的对象，你知道，在这个新状态下为你。而且它有点，你可以有点，你知道，传递那种像这种日期转换后的字符串。你可以把它传给不同的函数
and things like that. Yeah, I mean, currently, you know, COBOL is up to COBOL 2014. But, you know, the vast majority of the updates in COBOL have been to basically modernize it for the platform. So like, for example, nowadays they're following the IEEE standard. So, you know, what happens if you divide by zero?
之类的。是的，我的意思是，目前，你知道，COBOL 已经到了 COBOL 2014。但是，你知道，COBOL 中的绝大多数更新基本上是为了使它现代化以适应平台。所以，例如，现在他们遵循 IEEE 标准。所以，你知道，如果你除以零会发生什么？
What happens if you have zero over zero, right? Like, how are these handled? Yeah, exactly. Like, all of that, you know, COBOL used to do its own thing. You know, I used to actually have a software floating point implementation, and they kind of scrapped all of that. Yeah, so it's a lot of like, how do we run our COBOL code on a MacBook or something like that, or the latest Intel machine or something?
如果你有零除以零会发生什么，对吧？就像，这些是如何处理的？是的，完全正确。就像，所有这些，你知道，COBOL 过去有它自己的做法。你知道，我过去实际上有一个软件浮点实现，他们有点废弃了所有这些。是的，所以这很多是关于，我们如何让我们的 COBOL 代码在 MacBook 或类似的东西上运行，或者最新的 Intel 机器之类的？
That's been the majority of the changes. Uh, you know, plurality of software managers, um, said they're either moving off COBOL already or they would if, if it was, if it was cheaper, but it's just too, too expensive to migrate all that code, which is kind of interesting. You know, it's, uh, I mean, if it's, if COBOL is any indicator of the future, you know, there's a lot of job security because, you know, there's constantly things being written in different languages. And so you need that expertise forever, effectively. So, yeah, I don't really know. I mean, what do you think, Patrick? Do you think that this is like a one-time thing because it happened when computers were so young? Or do you think that this phenomena of always needing a COBOL engineer,
这就是大部分的变化。嗯，你知道，多数软件经理，嗯，说他们要么已经放弃了 COBOL，要么如果，如果它更便宜的话他们会放弃，但迁移所有这些代码太贵了，这很有趣。你知道，它，嗯，我的意思是，如果 COBOL 是未来的任何指标，你知道，有很多工作保障，因为，你知道，不断有东西用不同的语言编写。所以你需要那种专业知识永远存在，实际上。所以，是的，我真的不知道。我的意思是，你怎么看，Patrick？你认为这是一次性的事情，因为它发生在计算机还很年轻的时候吗？还是你认为这种总是需要 COBOL 工程师的现象，
that that's going to happen for every language? I think there's precedent for that being a thing. But I mean, for something like COBOL, there's enough people using it, enough lines of code written, enough support that support continues. A lot of projects will die off. So if you're writing in something, I'd i'd hate to use an example so i won't but i'll use an example k there's actually a language k that okay so at some point you get too few people using it
这会发生在每种语言上吗？我认为有先例证明这是一回事。但我的意思是，对于像 COBOL 这样的东西，有足够多的人在使用它，编写了足够多的代码行，有足够的支持，所以支持会继续。很多项目会消亡。所以如果你在用某种东西编写，我，我讨厌使用一个例子，所以我不会，但我会使用一个例子 K，实际上有一种语言 K，好的，所以到某个时候，使用它的人太少了
so unless your specific use is so valuable and impossible to get off of basically you're not going to find someone who's going to maintain the compiler or maintain an os and even if you run an old compiler on an old os eventually your hardware is going to be replacing and you're going to run out of people who make those kinds of processors anymore so imagine like all of the systems that were like apple computers used to run on power pcs at some point your thing that was running on a power pc that doesn't have an intel based compiler an x86 compiler um you that power pc you're gonna pay more and more to get replacements and eventually one day they're gonna run out you're not gonna be able to get a you know parts for your power pc computer um and if your language never had an x86 compiler you're faced with this like paying a vast sum of money
所以除非你的特定用途非常有价值且无法摆脱，基本上你找不到会维护编译器或维护操作系统的人，即使你在旧操作系统上运行旧编译器，最终你的硬件也会被更换，你将不再有制造那种处理器的人了，所以想象一下，所有像 Apple 计算机过去在 Power PC 上运行的系统，在某个时候，你在 Power PC 上运行的东西，没有基于 Intel 的编译器，x86 编译器，嗯，那个 Power PC，你将支付越来越多的钱来获得替换品，最终有一天它们会用完，你将无法获得，你知道，你的 Power PC 计算机的零件，如果你的语言从来没有 x86 编译器，你面临着这种，支付巨额资金
to get someone, you know, it's probably more expensive to get someone to port their compiler than to just rewrite your application at that point or whatever. So for things where there's not enough of an install base, I don't think you end up with this happening at sort of the limit.
来找人，你知道，在那一点上，找人移植他们的编译器可能比直接重写你的应用程序更贵，或者其他什么。所以对于安装基础不够的东西，我不认为你会最终在某种极限上发生这种情况。
Right, right. But for some things, there's enough of a, that's not true. Like, because for cobalt maintaining the compiler makes a lot of sense because there's so many people using it you're dividing up that resource cost amongst all of those people yeah it makes sense i think uh for any language let's say for any language we talked about in the show except for that show we had on esoteric languages but but for any other all the other you know 60 some odd languages we've covered or maybe 50 some odd languages i would say any of them will survive like survive insofar as if you specialized in any of them you know you'll be needed let's say 20
对，对。但对于某些东西，有足够的，那不是真的。就像，因为对于 COBOL，维护编译器非常有意义，因为有很多人在使用它，你把资源成本分摊给了所有这些人，是的，这有道理，我想，嗯，对于任何语言，比如说对于我们在节目中谈到的任何语言，除了我们关于深奥语言的那一期，但对于任何其他，所有其他，你知道，我们涵盖的 60 多种语言，或者也许 50 多种语言，我会说它们中的任何一个都会存活，就像存活一样，如果你专门研究它们中的任何一个，你知道，你会被需要，比如说 20
years from now but the question is one of sort of, I guess, supply and demand that if, you know, so the specialists are still needed. But the question is, like, is it like is or is the team you're working on valuing that stuff? So if you're like the only, you know, it's the classic example, I guess, of do you always I don't know if it's actually true. There's like two surviving Picasso paintings and some person buys both and destroys one because one is worth much more than the two together. Oh, yeah. Marginal cost. So if you sort of say that like you're the only cobalt expert in the whole entire world, you probably charge a lot of money. But if there are lots of cobalt experts and it's maintenance, not new development. And so people sort of don't need that much work or don't value it that highly and they're already sort of saying they're price sensitive is one of
年之后，但问题是某种，我想，供需关系，如果，你知道，所以专家仍然被需要。但问题是，就像，是，或者你工作的团队是否重视那些东西？所以如果你是唯一的，你知道，这是经典的例子，我想，你是否总是，我不知道这是否是真的。有两幅幸存的毕加索画作，某人买了两幅并销毁了一幅，因为一幅比两幅加起来更有价值。哦，是的。边际成本。所以如果你说你可能是全世界唯一的 COBOL 专家，你可能会收取很多钱。但如果有大量的 COBOL 专家，而且它是维护，而不是新开发。所以人们有点不需要那么多工作，或者不那么重视它，而且他们已经有点说他们对价格敏感是
the reasons they're not moving off then like the question is is it lucrative enough for you to continue doing it and that's a question each person has to make on their own yeah yeah totally yeah i think that's a good point like uh you know if like for example like coffee script was kind of a really big thing now i mean there's still using CoffeeScript, but it's much less popular. And so, yeah, I think, as you said, it's a supply-demand thing. Like, if a bunch of people get super hyped about some language and then it falls off the face of the earth, that's kind of the worst because now there's so many people who are experts and not enough kind of work to do yeah so cobalt um often is although it can be done on other stuff often is used in uh alongside of running the cobalt code on a mainframe oh i said that poorly anyways uh and so the idea here is we wanted to also briefly talk about mainframes
他们不放弃的原因之一，那么问题是，它是否足够有利可图让你继续做下去，这是一个每个人都必须自己做出的决定。是的，是的，完全正确，是的，我认为这是一个很好的观点，就像，嗯，你知道，如果，例如，像 CoffeeScript 曾经是一件大事，现在，我的意思是，仍然有人在使用 CoffeeScript，但它不那么流行了。所以，是的，我想，正如你所说，这是一个供需问题。就像，如果一群人对某种语言超级炒作，然后它从地球表面消失了，那是最糟糕的，因为现在有太多人是专家，而没有足够的工作可做。是的，所以 COBOL，嗯，通常是，虽然它可以在其他东西上完成，但通常用于，嗯，在大型机上运行 COBOL 代码的同时，哦，我说的很差，无论如何，嗯，所以这里的想法是我们也想简要谈谈大型机
which is nothing something we've not talked about before and it's not something i personally have much experience with although i have used them a couple times oh really wait hang on how have you used them because i've never even seen one i've i've not seen it but so i mean i worked uh i did intern at a company that did back-end banking software and so all this stuff was run on mainframes and so you had uh i guess you'd call it a terminal emulator to the mainframe. And it's like very strange. And, you know, it's something if you've never done before, it seems sort of weird. But in just, you know, just to go to high level, so people sort of have some amount of background.
这是我们以前没有谈论过的东西，也不是我个人有很多经验的东西，虽然我确实用过几次，哦真的，等等，等等，你怎么用过它们，因为我甚至没见过一个，我，我没见过它，但所以，我的意思是，我工作，嗯，我在一家做后端银行软件的公司实习过，所以所有这些东西都是在大型机上运行的，所以你有，嗯，我想你会称之为大型机终端模拟器。而且它非常奇怪。而且，你知道，如果你以前从未做过，它看起来有点奇怪。但只是，你知道，只是为了达到高水平，所以人们有点背景。
This is by no means an in-depth covering of either of these topics. But about mainframes is that you want, you know, sort of a single system that has very efficient throughput as a single system, but it's also very reliable. So if you imagine instead of having like a distributed database, if you wanted to say, I want a machine that just has a very giant amount of Ram and a really fast processor. And I want to do things that's like every customer in my bank has a, you know, entry in my ledger that's stored in this giant memory database. And I want to,
这绝不是对这两个主题的深入报道。但关于大型机是，你想要，你知道，某种具有非常高效吞吐量的单一系统，但它也非常可靠。所以如果你想象一下，与其拥有像分布式数据库，如果你想说，我想要一台只有非常巨大的内存和非常快的处理器的机器。我想做的事情就像我银行里的每个客户都有一个，你知道，存储在这个巨大内存数据库中的分类账条目。我想，
you know, give everyone the interest their account accrued each night. And so for each night, I want to go through all of my customers and, you know, figure out how much interest they've earned, update their account. I want to do it. And this is where the batch comes in i want to do it fast so i'm doing it on a mainframe that specializes this kind of work and i'm doing it batch processing which sort of says i want to do all of these things together but i want each of them to be atomic so if i sort of you know get jason's you know bank account amounts and calculate his and for this it's not important but you know calculate his interest and then i want to update it I want that to happen atomically. So in that case, you're only doing one thing, updating a single number. But if you were
你知道，给每个人他们账户每晚产生的利息。所以对于每个晚上，我想遍历我所有的客户，你知道，算出他们赚了多少利息，更新他们的账户。我想做它。这就是批处理进来的地方，我想快速做它，所以我是在一台专门从事这种工作的的大型机上做的，我是在做批处理，这有点说我想把所有这些事情放在一起做，但我希望它们中的每一个都是原子的，所以如果我有点，你知道，得到 Jason 的，你知道，银行账户金额并计算他的，对于这个，它不重要，但你知道，计算他的利息，然后我想更新它，我希望它原子地发生。所以在那种情况下，你只做一件事，更新一个数字。但如果你是
updating multiple things, you would want them to sort of all either happen or not happen in case of a problem. So that if you do run into an issue, you don't have someone's account left in a bad state. IE, you know, I was able to left in a bad state, i.e., you know, I was able to withdraw money and get cash out of the ATM and my bank account balance didn't go down. Right, right. You know, and that would be bad because the bank lost money, that money disappeared and they don't know where it went. That would be horrible. And so they need systems that are reliable and a method of executing that you know sort of also has this redundancy built in um and all computing used to be done on these i guess mainframes was
更新多件事，你会希望它们有点全部发生或全部不发生，以防出现问题。这样如果你确实遇到了问题，你就不会让某人的账户处于糟糕的状态。即，你知道，我能够处于糟糕的状态，即，你知道，我能够提取钱并从 ATM 取出现金，而我的银行账户余额没有下降。对，对。你知道，那会很糟糕，因为银行损失了钱，那笔钱消失了，他们不知道它去了哪里。那会很可怕。所以他们需要可靠的系统和一种执行方法，你知道，某种程度上也内置了这种冗余，嗯，所有的计算过去都是在这些，我想大型机上完成的，是
sort of like kind of the only way of doing things and people would sort of time share on these mainframes and there would be jobs and each job would be executed and the next one and then the next one um but now it's sort of different it's often used in these you know i want redundancy i don't want redundancy in that two different computers are sort of both working on this task and you know hopefully it'll work which is a lot of you know like if i go to we talked about before like if you go to the new york times and some part of it doesn't work it's bad but no one's like out tons of money or, or,
某种，你知道，做事情的唯一方式，人们会有点在这些大型机上分时共享，会有作业，每个作业会被执行，然后是下一个，然后是下一个，嗯，但现在它有点不同，它通常用于这些，你知道，我想要冗余，我不想要冗余，即两台不同的计算机都在处理这个任务，而且，你知道，希望它能工作，这很多，你知道，就像如果我去，我们之前谈过的，就像如果你去纽约时报，它的某部分不能工作，这很糟糕，但没有人损失大量金钱，或者，或者，
or, you know, dying because of it. Um, but if you're in a bank, you really don't want to not know. And it's, it is actually true that it's pretty difficult to coordinate across systems to
或者，你知道，因此而死亡。嗯，但如果你在银行，你真的不想不知道。而且，它确实是真的，跨系统协调以
get that reliability. You have to see this in the, uh, you see that member, that article of people who could figure out how to duplicate items in games? Like, there's this thing where someone would know sort of where the boundary of the zone is. Like, it's not visible, but they just kind of know from the code. They're like, you know, I'm in World of Warcraft zone A, but if I take one step over, I'm in zone B.
获得那种可靠性非常困难。你必须在，嗯，你看到那篇关于人们如何弄清楚如何在游戏中复制物品的文章吗？就像，有这样一件事，有人会知道某种区域边界在哪里。就像，它不可见，但他们只是从代码中知道。他们就像，你知道，我在魔兽世界 A 区，但如果我走一步，我就在 B 区。
And they would actually give an item to their friend and then just take this tiny step, I'm in zone B. And they would actually give an item to their friend and then just take this tiny step from zone A to zone B. And it would actually end up with two items because the give command would fail in the second zone, but at the same time it would pass in the first zone. And now there's two copies of that item. And obviously when you're dealing with real money, you can't do that. So a mainframe would kind of avoid
他们实际上会把一个物品给他们的朋友，然后只是迈出这一小步，我在 B 区。他们实际上会把一个物品给他们的朋友，然后只是迈出从 A 区到 B 区的这一小步。它实际上会以两个物品告终，因为给予命令在第二个区域会失败，但同时它会在第一个区域通过。现在那个物品有两个副本。显然当你处理真钱时，你不能那样做。所以大型机会有点避免
that. And so I mean, I'm not sure, you know, again, this is not my area of expertise. I don't hear of a lot of new development happening in sort of like great new features of mainframes. But I'm absolutely sure that tons and tons of new code gets written every year that work on mainframes
那样。所以我的意思是，我不确定，你知道，再次，这不是我的专业领域。我没有听说过大型机有很多新的开发，比如大型机的新功能。但我绝对确定每年都有大量的新代码被编写，在大型机上工作
in this case yeah also you know one thing we haven't really talked on and again it's not really my background but um is report generation for the purposes of auditing for the purposes of people to do overview um and not just in banking actually in lots of different software engineering fields report generation is very important um but mainframesframes and COBOL are two things that very specifically you want to roll up like I want to know how much money is in a given branch of a bank and I want to know you know how many current deposits do I have how many you know the accounting balance sheet right you want to be able to get reports of where every penny is and where it's
在这种情况下，是的，还有，你知道，我们没有真正谈论的一件事，再次，这不是我的背景，嗯，是用于审计目的、用于人们做概述目的的报告生成，而且不仅仅是在银行，实际上在许多不同的软件工程领域，报告生成非常重要，但大型机和 COBOL 是两件你非常具体地想要汇总的事情，比如我想知道银行的一个分支机构有多少钱，我想知道，你知道，我有多少当前存款，我有多少，你知道，会计资产负债表，对吧，你想要能够获得每一分钱在哪里以及它
coming from and where it's going to and you need to generate those each night and check them for consistency it be reliable and redundant and backed up all of those things i mean a lot is at stake and so that's the realm where you find these things yeah that makes sense i mean i think one of the things that really killed the mainframe is paxos so pa Paxos is this like, I guess algorithm. Oh, we do not have time to get into that. Yeah, yeah, we can't cover it. We're already running super late. But it basically allows a lot
来自哪里以及它要去哪里的报告，你需要每晚生成这些报告并检查它们的一致性，它必须可靠、冗余并备份所有这些东西，我的意思是，很多东西都处于危险之中，所以这就是你发现这些东西的领域，是的，这有道理，我的意思是，我认为真正杀死大型机的一件事是 Paxos，所以 Paxos 是这个，我想，算法。哦，我们没有时间深入研究那个。是的，是的，我们不能涵盖它。我们已经运行得超级晚了。但它基本上允许很多
of machines to coordinate. And I think we've actually talked about it in the past. Maybe we have a consensus algorithm. If you search Paxos on our site, you can find it. If not, maybe we'll cover it in the next show. Send us an email if you want us to cover Paxos. But I think that really is what killed the mainframe market because all of a sudden now a group of computers
机器进行协调。而且我想我们过去实际上谈论过它。也许我们有一个共识算法。如果你在我们的网站上搜索 Paxos，你可以找到它。如果没有，也许我们会在下一期节目中涵盖它。如果你想让我们涵盖 Paxos，给我们发电子邮件。但我认为那确实是杀死大型机市场的原因，因为突然之间现在一组计算机
could kind of do the same thing. All right, cool. So, yeah, that's COBOL, mainframes, game theory, all sorts of cool stuff, algorithms and pythons. We had a lot of stuff to cover this episode. I hope you guys appreciate it. Sorry it went a little bit long, but we had a ton of content. It's been a long time.
可以有点做同样的事情。好的，酷。所以，是的，这就是 COBOL，大型机，博弈论，各种酷东西，算法和 Python。我们这一集有很多东西要涵盖。我希望你们欣赏它。抱歉它有点长，但我们有大量的内容。已经很长时间了。
It's been almost, what, three months since we had a non-interview show. So we had a lot we wanted to tell you about. And thank you again for all of your support. Looking forward to only a few months until Christmas, we start giving away some t-shirts. So if you haven't signed up on Patreon, go ahead and sign up. Even if you can only give a dollar, that's totally fine. You can give a dollar and end up winning like a $20 t-shirt. It can happen. So thanks for all your support. Check out the books of the show, tool of the show, and send us
已经快，什么，三个月了，自从我们有非采访节目以来。所以我们有很多想告诉你们的事情。再次感谢你们所有的支持。期待离圣诞节只有几个月了，我们开始赠送一些 T 恤。所以如果你还没有在 Patreon 上注册，请去注册。即使你只能给一美元，那也完全没问题。你可以给一美元，最终赢得一件 20 美元的 T 恤。这可能会发生。所以感谢你们所有的支持。看看节目的书籍，节目的工具，并发送给我们
all your feedback. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Sharealike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你所有的反馈。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下分发的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行重混、改编作品，但你必须提供给 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。